neural networks are good for learning
lots of different types of patterns to
give an example of how this would work
imagine you had a four pixel camera so
not not four megapixels but just four
pixels and it was only black and white
and you wanted to go around and take
pictures of things and determine
automatically then whether these
pictures were of solid all white or all
dark image vertical line or a diagonal
line or a horizontal line this is tricky
because you can't do this with simple
rules about the brightness of the pixels
both of these are horizontal lines but
if you tried to make a rule about which
pigment pixel was bright and which was
dark you wouldn't be able to do it so to
do this with the neural network you
start by taking all of your inputs in
this case our four pixels and you break
them out into input neurons and you
assign a number to each of these
depending on the brightness or darkness
of the pixel plus one is all the way
white minus one is all the way black and
then gray is zero right in the middle so
[Music]
these values once you haven't broken out
and listed like this on the input
neurons it's also called the input
vector or array it's just a list of
numbers that represents your inputs
right now it's a useful notion to think
about the receptive field of a neuron
all this means is what set of inputs
makes the value of this neuron as high
as it can possibly be for input neurons
this is pretty easy each one is
associated with just one pixel and when
that pixel is all the way quite the
value of that input neuron is as high as
it could go the black and white
checkered areas show pixels that an
input neuron doesn't care about if
they're all the way white or all the way
black it still doesn't affect the value
of that input
not at all now to build a neural network
we create a neuron the first thing this
does is it adds up all of the values of
the input neurons so in this case we if
we add up all of those values we get a
point five now to complicate things just
a little bit each of the connections are
weighted meaning they're multiplied by a
number that number can be 1 or minus 1
or anything in between so for instance
if something has a weight of minus 1 its
multiplied and you get the negative of
it and that's added in if something has
a weight of 0 then it's effectively
ignored so here's what those weighted
connections might look like you'll
notice that after the values of the
input neurons are weighted and added the
values come that the final value is
completely different graphically it's
convenient to represent these weights as
white links being positive weights black
links being negative weights and the
thickness of the line is roughly
proportional to the magnitude of the
weight then after you add the weighted
input neurons they get squashed and I'll
show you what that means you have a
sigmoid squashing function sigmoid just
means s-shaped and what this does is you
put a value in let's say 0.5 and you run
a vertical line up to your sigmoid and
then a horizontal line over from where
it crosses and then where that hits the
y-axis that's the output of your
function so in this case slightly less
than 0.5 it's pretty close as your input
number gets larger your output number
also gets larger but more slowly and
eventually no matter how big the number
you put in the answer is always less
than 1
similarly when you go negative the
answer is always greater than negative
one so this ensures that that neurons
value never gets outside of the range of
plus 1 to minus 1 which is helpful for
keeping the computations in the neural
network bounded and stable so after you
sum the weighted values of neurons and
squash the result you get the output in
this case 0.746 that is a neuron so we
can call this we can collapse all that
down and this is a neuron that does a
weighted sum and squash the result and
now instead of just one of those assume
you have a whole bunch there are 4 shown
here but there could be 400 or 4 million
now to keep our picture clear we'll
assume for now that the weights are
either +1 white lines minus 1 black
lines or 0 in which case they're missing
entirely but in actuality all of these
neurons that we created are each
attached to all of the input neurons and
they all have some weight between minus
1 and plus 1 when we create this first
layer of our neural network the
receptive fields get more complex
for instance here each of those end up
combining two of our input neurons and
so the value the receptive field the
pixel values that make that first layer
neuron as large as it can possibly be
look now like pairs of pixels either all
white or a mixture of white black
depending on the weights so for instance
this neuron here is attached to this
input pixel which is upper-left and this
input pixel which is lower left and both
of those weights are positive so it
combines the
of those and that's it's receptive field
the receptive field of this one plus the
receptive field of this one however if
we look at this neuron it combines our
this pixel upper right and this pixel
lower right it has a weight of minus one
for the lower right pixel so that means
it's most active when this pixel is
black so here as its receptive field now
the because we were careful of how we
created that first layer its values look
a lot like input values and we can turn
right around and create another layer on
top of it the exact same way with the
output of one layer being the input to
the next layer and we can repeat this
three times or seven times or seven
hundred times for additional layers each
time the receptive fields get even more
complex so you can see here using the
same logic
now they cover all of the pixels and
more more special arrangement of which
are black and which are white we can
create another layer again all of these
neurons in one layer are connected to
all of the neurons in the previous layer
but we're assuming here that most of
those weights are zero and not shown
it's not generally the case so just to
mix things up we'll create a new layer
but if you notice our squashing function
isn't there anymore we have something
new called a rectified linear unit this
is another popular neuron type so you do
your weighted sum of all your inputs and
instead of squashing you do rectified
linear units you rectify it so if it is
negative you make the value zero if it's
positive you keep the value this is
obviously very easy to compute and it
turns out
to have very nice stability properties
for neural networks as well in practice
so after we do this because some of our
weights are positive and some are
negative connecting to those rectified
linear units we get receptive fields and
they're opposites you look at the
patterns there and then finally when
we've created as many layers with as
many neurons as we want we create an
output layer here we have four outputs
that were interested in is the image
solid vertical diagonal or horizontal so
to walk through an example here of how
this would work let's say we start with
this input image shown on the Left dark
pixels on top white on the bottom as we
propagate that to our input layer this
is what those values would look like the
top pixels the bottom pixels as we move
that to our first layer we can see the
combination of a dark pixel and a light
pixel sum together
get us zero gray whereas down here we
have the combination of a dark pixel
plus a light pixel with a negative
weight so that gets us a value of
negative one there which makes sense
because if we look at the receptive
field here upper left pixel white lower
left pixel black is the exact opposite
of the input that we're getting and so
we would expect its value to be as low
as possible minus one as we move to the
next layer we see the same types of
things combining zeros to get zeros
combining a negative and a negative with
a negative weight which makes a positive
to get a zero and here we have combining
two negatives to get a negative so again
you'll notice the receptive field of
this it's exactly the inverse of our
input so it makes sense
that it's weight would be negative or as
a value would be negative and we move to
the next layer all of these of course
these zero is propagate forward here
this is a negative has a negative value
and it gets has a positive weight so it
just moves straight forward because we
have a rectified linear unit negative
values become zero so now it is zero
again two but this one gets rectified
and becomes positive negative times a
negative is positive and so when we
finally get to the output we can see
they're all zero except for this
horizontal which is positive and that's
the answer our neural network said this
is an image of a horizontal line now
neural networks usually aren't that good
not that clean so there's a notion of
with an input what is truth in this case
the truth is this has a zero for all of
these values but a one for horizontal
it's not solid it's not vertical it's
not diagonal yes it is horizontal an
arbitrary neural network will give
answers that are not exactly truth it
might be off by a little or a lot and
then the error is the magnitude of the
difference between the truth and the
answer given and you can add all these
up to get the total error for the neural
network so the idea the whole idea with
learning and training is to adjust the
weights to make the error as low as
possible so the way this is done is we
put an image in we calculate the error
at the end then we look for how to
adjust those weights higher or lower to
either make that error go up or down and
we of course adjust the weights in the
way then make the error go down now the
problem with doing this is each time we
go back and calculate the error we have
to multiply all of those weights by all
of the
values at each layer and we have to do
that again and again once for each
weight this takes forever
in computing terms on computing scale
and so it's not a practical way to train
a big neural network you can imagine
instead of just rolling down to the
bottom of a simple valley we have a very
high dimensional Valley and we have to
find our way down and because there are
so many dimensions one for each of these
weights that the computation just
becomes prohibitively expensive luckily
there was an insight that lets us do
this in a very reasonable time and
that's that if we're careful about how
we design our neural network we can
calculate the slope directly the
gradient we can figure out the direction
that we need to adjust the weight
without going all the way back through
our neural network and recalculating
so just review the slope that we're
talking about is when we make a change
in weight the error will change a little
bit and that relation of the change in
weight the change in error is the slope
mathematically there are several ways to
write this will favor the one on the
bottom it's technically most correct
we'll call it de DW for shorthand every
time you see it just think the change in
error when I change a weight or the
change in the thing on the top when I
change the thing on the bottom this is
does get into a little bit of calculus
we do take derivatives that's how we
calculate slope if it's new to you I
strongly recommend a good semester of
calculus just because the concepts are
so universal and a lot of them have very
nice physical interpretations which I
find very appealing but don't worry
otherwise just gloss over this and pay
attention to the rest and you'll get a
general sense for how this works so in
this case if we change the weight by
plus one the error changes
by minus two which gives us a slope of
minus two that tells us the direction
that we should adjust our weight and how
much we should adjust it to bring the
error down now to do this you have to
know what your error function is so
assume we had error function that was
the square of the weight and you can see
that our weight is right up minus one so
the first thing we do is we take the
derivative change in error divided by
change in weight de DW the derivative of
weight squared is two times the weight
and so we plug in our weight of minus
one and we get a slope de DW of minus
two now the other trick that lets us do
this with deep neural networks is
chaining and to show you how this works
imagine a very simple trivial neural
network with just one hidden layer one
input layer one output layer and one
weight connecting each of them so it's
obvious to see that the value Y is just
the value of x times the weight
connecting them w1 so if we change w1 a
little bit we just take the derivative
of Y with respect to w1 and we get X the
slope is X if I change w1 by a little
bit then Y will change by x times the
size of that adjustment similarly for
the next step we can see that e is just
the value Y times the weight w2 and so
when we calculate de dy it's just w2
because this network is so simple we can
calculate from one end to the other
x times w1 times w2 is the error E and
so if we want to calculate how much will
the error change if I change w1 we just
take the derivative of that with respect
to w1 and get x times w2 so this
illustrates you can see here now that
what we just calculated is actually the
product of our first derivative that we
took
the dy d w1 times the derivative for the
next step
de dy multiplied together this is
chaining you can calculate the slope of
each tiny step and then multiply all of
those together to get the slope of the
full chain the derivative of the full
chain so in a deeper neural network what
this would look like is if I want to
know how much the error will change if I
adjust a weight that's deep in the
network I just calculate the derivative
of each tiny little step all the way
back to the weight that I'm trying to
calculate and then multiply them all
together this computationally is many
many times cheaper than what we had to
do before of recalculating the error for
the whole neural network for every
weight now in the neural network that
we've created there are several types of
that propagation we have to do
there are several operations we have to
do for each one of those we have to be
able to calculate the slope so for the
first one is just a weighted connection
between two neurons a and B so let's
assume we know the change in error with
respect to B we want to know the change
in error with respect to a to get there
we need to know DB da so to get that we
just write the relationship between B
and a take the derivative of B with
respect to a we get the weight W and now
we know how to make that step we know
how to do that little nugget of back
propagation another element that we've
seen is sums all of our neurons sum up a
lot of inputs to take this brat back
propagation step we do the same thing we
write our expression and then we take
the derivative of our endpoint Z with
respect to our step that were
propagating to a and DZ da in this case
is just 1
which makes sense if we have a sum of a
whole bunch of elements we increase one
of those elements by one we expect the
sum to increase by one that's the
definition of a slope of one one-to-one
relation there another element that we
have that we need to be able to back
propagate is the sigmoid function so
this one's a little bit more interesting
mathematically we'll just write it
shorthand like this the Sigma function
it is entirely feasible to go through
and take the derivative of this
analytically and calculate it it just so
happens that this function has a nice
property that to get its derivative you
just multiply it by one minus itself so
this is very straightforward to
calculate another element that we've
used is the rectified linear unit again
to figure out how to back propagate this
we just write out the relation B is
equal to a if a is positive otherwise
it's zero and piecewise for each of
those we take the derivative so DB da is
either one if a is positive or zero and
so with all of these little back
propagation steps and the ability to
chain them together we can calculate the
effect of adjusting any given weight on
the error for any given input and so to
train then we start with a fully
connected Network we don't know what any
of these weights should be and so we
assign them all random values we create
a completely arbitrary random neural
network we put in an input that we know
the answer to we know whether it's solid
vertical diagonal or horizontal so we
know what truth should be and so we can
calculate the error then we run it
through calculate the error and using
back propagation
go through and adjust all of those
weights a tiny bit in the right
direction and then we do that again with
another input and again with another
input for if we can get away with it
many thousands or even millions of times
and eventually all of those weights will
gravitate they'll roll down that many
dimensional valley to a nice low spot in
the bottom where it performs really well
and does pretty close to truth on most
of the images if we're really lucky
it'll look like what we started with
with intuitively understandable
receptive fields for those neurons and a
relatively sparse representation meaning
that most of the weights are small or
close to zero and it doesn't always turn
out that way
but what we aren't guaranteed is that
it'll find a pretty good representation
of you know the best that it can do
adjusting those weights to get as close
as possible to the right answer for all
of the inputs so what we've covered is
just a very basic introduction to the
principles behind neural networks I
haven't told you quite enough to be able
to go out and build one of your own but
if you're feeling motivated to do so I
highly encourage it here are a few
resources that you'll find useful you'll
want to go and learn about biased
neurons dropout is a useful training
tool
there are several resources available
from Andre karpati who is an expert in
neural networks and great at teaching
about it also though there's a fantastic
article called the black magic of deep
learning that just has a bunch of
practical from the trenches tips on how
to get them working well
neural networks are famously difficult
to interpret it's hard to know what
they're actually learning when we train
them so let's take a closer look and see
whether we can get a good picture of
what's going on inside just like every
other supervised machine learning model
neural networks learn relationships
between input variables and output
variables in fact we can even see how
it's related to the most iconic model of
all linear regression simple linear
regression assumes a straight line
relationship between an input variable X
and an output variable Y X is multiplied
by a constant M which also happens to be
the slope of the line and it's added to
another constant B which happens to be
where the line crosses the y axis we can
represent this in a picture our input
value X is multiplied by M our constant
B is multiplied by 1 and then they get
added together to get Y this is a
graphical representation of y equals MX
plus B on the far left the circular
symbols just indicate that the value is
passed through the rectangles leghul
labeled M and B indicate that whatever
goes in on the Left comes out multiplied
by M or B on the right and the box with
the capital Sigma indicates that
whatever goes in on the left it gets
added together and spit out on the right
we can change the names of all the
symbols for a different representation
this is still a straight worth line
relationship we've just changed the
names of all the variables the reason
we're doing this is to translate our
linear regression into the notation
we'll use in neural networks this will
help us keep track of things as we move
forward at this point we have turned a
straight line equation into a network a
network is anything that has nodes
connected by edges in the
case X sub 0 and X sub 1 our our input
nodes V sub 0 is an output node and our
weights connecting them our edges this
is not the traditional sense of a graph
meaning a plot or a grid like in a
graphing calculator or graph paper it's
just the formal word for a network for
nodes connected by edges another piece
of terminology you might hear is a
directed acyclic graph abbreviated as da
G or dag a directed graph is one where
the edges just go in one direction in
our case input goes to output but output
never goes back to input our edges are
directed acyclic means that you can't
ever draw a loop once you have visited a
node there's no way to jump from edges
to nodes to edges to nodes to get back
to where you started
everything flows in one direction
through the graph we can get a sense of
the type of models that this network is
capable of learning by choosing random
values for the weights W sub 0 0 and W
sub 1 0 and then seeing what
relationship pops out between X sub 1
and V sub 0 remember that we set X sub 0
equal to 1 and are holding it there
always this is a special node called a
bias node it should come as no surprise
that the relationships that come out of
this linear model are all straight lines
after all we've taken our equation for
the line and rearranged it but we
haven't changed it in any substantial
way there's no reason we have to limit
ourselves to just one input variable we
can add an additional one now here we
have an X of 0 and X of 1 and an X sub 2
we draw an edge between X sub 2 and our
summation with the weight W sub twos
X of 2 times W sub 2 0 is again u sub 2
0 and all of our use get added together
to make a V sub 0 and we could add more
inputs as many as we want this is still
a linear equation but instead of being
two-dimensional we can make it three
dimensional or higher writing this out
mathematically could get very tedious so
we'll use a shortcut we'll substitute
the subscript I for the index of the
input it's the number of the input we're
talking about this allows us to write U
sub i's 0 where our u sub I equals X sub
I times W sub i's 0 and again our output
V sub 0 is just the summation over all
values of I of U sub i's ero for this
three-dimensional case we can again look
at the models that emerge when we
randomly choose our W sub I zeros our
weights as we would expect we still get
the three-dimensional equivalent of a
line a plane in this case and if we were
to extend this to more inputs we would
get the M dimensional equivalent of a
line which is called an M dimensional
hyper plane so far so good now we could
start to get fancier our input X sub 1
looks a lot like our output V sub 0 in
fact there's nothing to prevent us from
taking our output and then using it as
an input to another network just like
this one now we have two separate
identical layers we can add a subscript
Roman numeral I and a subscript Roman
numeral III or two to our equations
depending on which layer were referring
to and we just have to remember that our
X sub 1 in layer 2
is the same as our V sub-zero in layer
one because these equations are
identical and each our layer each of our
layers work just the same we can reduce
this to one set of equations adding a
subscript capital L to represent which
layer we're talking about as we continue
here we'll be assuming that all the
layers are identical and to keep the
equations cleaner we'll leave out the
capital L but just keep in mind that if
we were going to be completely correct
in verbose we would add the L subscript
on to the end of everything to specify
the layer it belongs to now that we have
two layers there's no reason that we
can't connect them in more than one
place instead of our first layer
generating just one output we can make
several outputs in our diagram we'll add
a second output V sub one and we'll
connect this to a third input into our
second layer X sub two keep in mind that
the X sub 0 input to every layer will
always be equal to 1 that bias node
shows up again and every layer now there
are two nodes shared by both layers we
can modify our equations accordingly to
specify which of the shared nodes we are
talking about they behave exactly the
same so we can be efficient and reuse
our equation but we can specify a
subscript J to indicate which output
we're talking about so now if I'm
connecting the 8th input to the jeaious
output then I and J will determine which
weight is applied and which use get
added together to create the output V
sub J and we can do this as many times
as we want we can add as many of these
shared nodes as we care to the model as
a whole only knows about the input X of
1
into the first layer and the output V
sub-zero of the last layer from the
point of view of someone sitting outside
the model the shared nodes between layer
1 and layer 2 are hidden they are inside
the black box because of this they're
called hidden nodes we can take this two
layer linear network create a hundred
hidden nodes said all of the weights
randomly and see what model it produces
even after adding all of this structure
the resulting models are still straight
lines in fact it doesn't matter how many
layers you have or how many hidden nodes
each layer has any combination of these
linear elements with weights and sums
will always produce a straight line
result this is actually one of the
traits of linear computation that makes
it so easy to work with but
unfortunately for us it also makes
really boring models sometimes a
straight line is good enough but that's
not why we go to neural networks we're
going to want something a little more
sophisticated in order to get more
flexible models we're going to need to
add some non-linearity we'll modify our
linear equation here after we calculate
our output V Sub Zero we subject it to
another function f which is not linear
and we'll call the result Y Sub Zero one
really common nonlinear function to add
here is the logistic function it's
shaped like an S so sometimes it's
called a sigmoid function two although
that can be confusing because
technically any function shaped like an
S is a sigmoid we can get a sense of
what logistic functions look like by
choosing random weights for this one
input one output one layer network and
meeting the family one notable
characteristic of logistic functions is
that they live between 0 and 1 for this
reason they're also called squashing
functions
you can imagine taking a straight line
and then squashing the edges and bending
and hammering it down so that the whole
thing fits between zero and one no
matter how far out you go
working with logistic functions brings
us to another connection with machine
learning models logistic regression this
is a bit confusing because regression
refers to finding a relationship between
an input and an output usually in the
form of a line or a curve or a surface
of some type logistic regression is
actually used as a classifier most of
the time it finds a relationship between
a continuous input variable and a
categorical output variable it treats
observations of one category as zeroes
treats observations of the other
category as ones and then finds the
logistic function that best fits all
those observations then to interpret the
model we add a threshold often around
0.5 and wherever the curve crosses the
threshold there's a demarcation line
everything to the left of that line is
predicted to fall into one category and
everything to the right of that line is
predicted to fall into the other this is
how a regression algorithm gets modified
to become a classification algorithm as
with linear functions there's no reason
not to add more inputs we know that
logistic regression can work with many
input variables and we can represent
that in our graph as well here we just
add one in order to keep the plot
3-dimensional but we could add as many
as we want to see what type of functions
this network can create we can choose a
bunch of random values for the weights
as you might have expected the functions
we create are still s-shaped but now
they're three-dimensional they look like
a tablecloth laid across two tables of
unequal height more importantly if you
look at the contour lines projected down
onto the floor of the plot you can see
that they are all perfectly straight
the result of this is that any threshold
we choose for doing classification will
split our input space up into two halves
with the divider being a straight line
this is why logistic regression is is
described as a linear classifier
whatever the number of inputs you have
whatever dimensional space you're
working in logistic regression will
always split it into two halves
using a line or a plane or a hyperplane
of the appropriate dimensions another
popular nonlinear function is the
hyperbolic tangent it's closely related
to the logistic function and can be
written in a very symmetric way we can
see when we choose some random weights
and look at examples that hyperbolic
tangent curves look just like logistic
curves except that they vary between
minus 1 and plus 1
just like we tried to do before with
linear functions we can use the output
of one layer as the input to another
layer we can stack them in this way and
can even add hidden nodes the same way
we did before here we just show two
hidden nodes in order to keep the
diagram simple but you can imagine as
many as you want there when we choose
random weights for this network and look
at the output we find that things get
interesting we've left the realm of the
linear because the hyperbolic tangent
function is nonlinear when we add them
together we get something that doesn't
necessarily look like a hyperbolic
tangent we get curves Wiggles peaks and
valleys and a much wider variety of
behavior than we ever saw with single
layer networks we can take the next step
and add another layer to our network now
we have a set of hidden nodes between
layer 1 and layer 2 and another set of
hidden nodes between layer 2 and layer 3
again we choose random values for all
the weights and look at the types of
curves that can
Douce again we see Wiggles and Peaks
valleys and a wide selection of shapes
if it's hard to tell the difference
between these curves and the curves
generated by a two layer network that's
because they're mathematically identical
we won't try to prove it here but
there's a cool result that shows that
any curve you can create learning of
many using a many layered Network you
can also create using a two layer
Network as long as you have enough
hidden nodes the advantage of having a
many layered Network is that it can help
you create more complex curves using
fewer total nodes for instance in our
two layer Network we used a hundred
hidden nodes better in our three layer
network we used eleven hidden nodes in
the first layer and nine hidden nodes in
the second layer that's only a fifth of
the total number we used in our two
layer network but the curves it produces
show similar richness we can use these
fancy Wiggly lines to make a classifier
as we did with logistic regression here
we use the zero line as the cutoff
everywhere that our curve crosses the
zero line there's a divider in every
region that the curve sits above the
zero line we'll call this category a and
similarly everywhere the curve is below
the zero line we have category B what
distinguishes these nonlinear
classifiers from linear ones is that
they don't just split the space into two
halves
in this example regions of a and B are
interleaved building a classifier around
a multi-layer nonlinear Network gives it
a lot more flexibility it can learn more
complex relations this particular
combination of multi-layer network with
hyperbolic tangent nonlinear function
has its own name a multi-layer
perceptron as you can guess when you
have only one layer as just called a
perceptron and in that case you don't
even need to add the nonlinear function
to make it work the function will still
cross the x-axis
all the same places here is the full
network diagram of a multi-layer
perceptron this representation is
helpful because it makes every single
operation explicit however it's also
visually cluttered and it's difficult to
work with because of this it's most
often simplified to look like circles
connected by lines this implies all the
operations we saw on the previous
diagram connecting lines each have a
weight associated with them hidden nodes
and output nodes perform summation and
non linear squashing but in this diagram
all of that is implied in fact our bias
nodes the notes that always have a value
of 1 in each layer are emitted for
clarity so our original network reduces
to this the bias nodes are still present
and their operation hasn't changed at
all but we leave them out to make a
cleaner picture we only show two hidden
nodes from each layer here but in
practice we used quite a few more again
to make the diagram as clean as possible
we often don't show all the hidden nodes
we just show a few and the rest are
implied here's a generic diagram then
for a three layer single input single
output Network notice that if we specify
the number of inputs the number of
outputs and the number of layers and the
number of hidden nodes in each layer
then we can fully define a neural
network we can also take a look at a two
input single output neural network
because it has two inputs when we plot
its outputs it'll be a three-dimensional
curve we can once again choose random
weights and generate curve to see what
types of functions this neural network
might be able to represent this is where
it gets really fun with multiple inputs
multiple layers and nonlinear activation
functions neural networks can make
really crazy shapes
it's almost correct to say that they
could make n
shape you want it's worth taking a
moment though to notice what its
limitations are first notice that all of
the functions fall between plus and
minus one the dark red and the dark
green regions kissed the floor and the
ceiling of this range but they never
cross it this neural network would not
be able to fit a function that extended
outside of this range also notice that
these functions all tend to be smooth
they have hills and dips and valleys and
wiggles and even points and wells but it
all happens relatively smoothly if we
hope to fit a function with a lot of
jagged jumps and drops this neural
network might not be able to do a very
good job of it however aside from these
two limitations the variety of functions
that this neural network can produce is
a little mind-boggling we modified a
single output neural network to be a
classifier when we looked at of the
multi-layer perceptron now there's
another way to do this we can use a to
output neural network instead outputs of
a three layer one input to output neural
network like this we can see that there
are many cases where the two curves
cross and in some instances they cross
in several places we can use this to
make a classifier wherever the one
output is greater than another it can
signify that one category dominates
another graphically wherever the two
output functions cross we can draw a
vertical line this chops up the input
space into regions in each region one
output is greater than the other
for instance wherever the blue line is
greater we can assign that to be
category a then wherever the peach
colored line is greater those regions
are category B just like the multi-layer
perceptron this lets us chop the space
up in more complex ways than a linear
classifier could regions of category a
and category B
can be shuffled together arbitrarily
when you only have two outputs the
advantages of doing it this way over a
multi-layer perceptron with just one
output are not at all clear however if
you move to three or more outputs the
story changes now we have three separate
outputs and three separate output
functions we can use our same criterion
of letting the function with the maximum
value determine the category we start by
chopping up the input space according to
which function has the highest value
each function represents one of our
categories we're going to assign our
first function to be category a and
label every region where it's on top as
category a then we can do the same with
our second function and our third using
this trick we are no longer limited to
two categories we can create as many
output nodes as we want and learn and
chop up the input space into that many
categories it's worth pointing out that
the winning category may not be the best
by very much in some cases you can see
they can be very close one category will
be declared the winner but the next
runner-up may be almost as good a fit
there's no reason that we can't extend
this approach to two or more inputs
unfortunately it does get harder to
visualize you have to imagine several of
these lumpy landscape plots on top of
each other and in some regions one will
be greater than the others in that
region that category associated with
that output will be dominant to get a
qualitative sense for what these regions
might look like you can look at the
projected contours on the floor of these
plots in the case of a multi-layer
perceptron these plots are all sliced at
the y equals zero level that means if
you look at the floor of the plot
everything in any shade of green will be
one cat
and everything in any shade of red will
be the other category the first thing
that jumps out about these category
boundaries is how diverse they are some
of them are nearly straight lines albeit
with a small wiggle some of them have
Wilder bends and curves and some of them
chop the input space up into several
disconnected regions of green and red
sometimes there's a small island of
green or island of red in the middle of
a sea of the other color the variety of
boundaries is what makes this such a
powerful classification tool the one
limitation we can see looking at it this
way is that the boundaries are all some
times those curves are quite sharp but
usually they're gentle and rounded this
shows the natural preference the neural
networks with hyperbolic tangent
activation functions have four smooth
functions and smooth boundaries the goal
of this exploration was to get an
intuitive sense for what types of
functions and category boundaries neural
networks can learn when used for
regression or classification we've seen
both their power and their distinct
preference for smoothness we've only
looked at two nonlinear activation
functions logistic and hyperbolic
tangent both of which are very closely
related there are lots of others and
some of them do a bit better at
capturing sharp nonlinearities rectified
linear units or real OU's for instance
produce surfaces and boundaries that are
quite a bit sharper but my hope was to
seed your intuition with some examples
of what's actually going on under the
hood when you train your neural network
here are the most important things to
walk away with neural networks learn
functions and can be used for regression
some activation functions limit the
output range but as long as that matches
the expected range of your outputs it's
not a problem
second neural networks are most often
used for classification they've proven
pretty good at it
third neural networks tend to create
smooth functions
when used for regression and smooth
category boundaries when used for
classification forth for fully connected
vanilla neural networks a two layer
network can learn any function that a
deep network can learn however a deep
network might be able to learn it with
fewer nodes v making sure that inputs
are normalized that is they have a mean
near zero and a standard deviation of
less than one this helps neural networks
to be more sensitive to their
relationships I hope this helps you as
you jump into your next project happy
building welcome to how convolutional
neural networks worked convolutional
neural networks or cog nets or CN NS can
do some pretty cool things if you feed
them a bunch of pictures of faces for
instance they learn some basic things
like edges and dots bright spots dark
spots and then because they are a
multi-layer neural network that's what
gets loaded in the first layer the
second layer are things that are
recognizable as eyes noses mouths and
the third layer are things that look
like theses similarly if you feed it a
bunch of images of cars down at the
lowest layer you'll get things again
that look like edges and then higher up
look at things that look like tires and
wheel wells and hoods and at a level
above that things that are clearly
identifiable as cars CN NS can even
learn to play video games by forming
patterns of the pixels as they appear on
the screen and learning what is the best
action to take when it sees a certain
pattern a CNN can learn to play video
games in some cases far better than a
human ever could not only that if you
take a couple of CN NS and have them set
to watching YouTube videos one can learn
objects by again picking out patterns
and the other one can learn types of
grasps
this then coupled with some other
execution software can let a robot learn
to cook just by watching YouTube so
there's no doubt CNN's are powerful
usually when we talk about them we do so
in the same way we might talk about
magic but they're not magic what they do
is based on some pretty basic ideas
apply it in a clever way so to
illustrate these we'll talk about a very
simple toy convolutional neural network
what this one does is takes in an image
a two-dimensional array of pixels you
can think of it as a checkerboard and
each square on the checkerboard is
either light or dark and then by looking
at that the CNN decides whether it's a
picture of an X or of an O so for
instance on top there we see an image
with an X drawn in white pixels on a
black background and we would like to
identify this as an X and the O we like
to identify as an O so how a CNN does
this is has several steps in it what
makes it tricky is that the X is not
exactly the same every time the actor
the O can be shifted it can be bigger or
smaller can be rotated a little bit
thicker or thinner and in every case we
would still like to identify it whether
it's an X or an O now the reason that
this is challenging is because for us
deciding whether these two things are
similar is straightforward we don't even
have to think about it for a computer
it's very hard what a computer sees is
this checkerboard this two-dimensional
array as a bunch of numbers ones and
minus ones a one is a bright pixel a
minus one is a black pixel and what it
can do is go through pixel by pixel and
compare whether they match or not so to
a computer to a computer it looks like
there are a lot of pixels that match but
some that don't quite a few that
actually and so it might look at this
and say I'm really not sure whether
these are the same and so it was because
a computer is so literal would say
uncertain I can't say that they're equal
now one of the tricks that convolutional
neural networks use is to match parts of
the image rather than the whole thing so
if you break it down into its smaller
parts or features then it becomes much
more clear whether these two things are
similar so examples of these little
features are little mini images in this
case just three pixels by three pixels
the one on the left is a diagonal line
slanting downward from left to right the
one on the right is also a diagonal line
slanting in the other direction and the
one in the middle is a little X these
are little pieces of the bigger image
and you can see as we go through if you
choose the right feature and put it in
the right place
it matches the image exactly so okay we
have the bits and pieces now to take a
step deeper there the math behind
matching these is called filtering and
the way this is done is a feature is
lined up with the little patch of the
image and then one by one the pixels are
compared they're multiplied by each
other and then added up and divided by
the total number of pixels so to step
through this to see why it makes sense
to do this you can see starting in the
upper left-hand pixel in both the
feature and the image patch multiplying
the 1 by a 1 if you will 1 and we can
keep track of that by putting that in
the position of the pixel that we're
comparing we step to the next one minus
1 times minus 1 is also a 1 and we
continue to step through pixel by pixel
multiplying them all by each other and
because they're always the same the
answer is always 1
when we're done we take all these ones
and add them up and divide by nine and
the answer is one so now we want to keep
track of where that feature was in the
image and we put a 1 there and say when
we put the feature here we get a match
of what that is filtering now we can
take that same feature and move it to
another position and perform the
filtering again and we start with the
same pattern the first pixel matches the
second pitch one matches the third pixel
does not match minus one times one
equals minus one so we record that in
our results and we go through and do
that through the rest of the image patch
and when we're done we notice we have
two minus ones this time so we add up
all the pixels to add up to 5/9 and we
get a point five five so this is very
different than our one and we can record
the point five five in that position
where we were where it occurred so by
moving our filter around to different
places in the image we actually find
different values for how well that
filter matches or how well that feature
is represented at that position so this
becomes a map of where the feature
occurs by moving it around to every
possible position we do convolution
that's just the repeated application of
this feature this filter over and over
again and what we get is a nice map
across the whole image of where this
feature occurs and if we look at it it
makes sense this feature is a diagonal
line slanting downward left to right
which matches the downward left-to-right
diagonal of the X so if we look at our
filtered image we see that all of the
high numbers ones and point seven seven
are all right along that diagonal that
suggests that that feature matches along
that diagonal much better than it does
elsewhere in the image
to use a shorthand notation here we'll
do a little X with a circle in it to
represent convolution the act of trying
every possible match and we repeat that
with other features we can repeat that
with our X filter in the middle and with
our upward slanting diagonal line in the
bottom and in each case the map that we
get of where that feature occurs is
consistent with what we would expect
based on what we know about the X and
about where our features match this act
of convolving an image with a bunch of
filters a bunch of features and creating
a stack of filtered images is we'll call
a convolution layer a layer because it's
an operation that we can stack with
others as we'll show in a minute in
convolution one image becomes a stack of
filtered images we get as many filtered
images out as we have filters so
convolution layer is one trick that we
have the next big trick that we have is
called pooling this is how we shrink the
image stack and this is pretty
straightforward we start with the window
size usually 2 by 2 pixels or 3 by 3
pixels and destryed usually 2 pixels
just in practice these work best and
then we take that window and walk it in
strides across each of the filtered
images from each window
we take the maximum value so to
illustrate this we start with our first
filtered image we have our two pixel by
2 pixel window within that pixel the
maximum value is 1 so we track that and
then move to our stride of 2 pixels we
move two pixels to the right and repeat
out of that window the maximum value is
0.33 etc 0.55 when we get to the end we
have to be creative we have don't have
all the pixels representative so we take
the max of what's there
and we continue doing this across the
whole image and when we're done what we
end up with is a similar pattern but
smaller we can still see our high values
are all on the diagonal but instead of 7
by 7 pixels in our filtered image we
have a 4 by 4 pixel image so as half as
big as it was about this makes a lot of
sense to do if you can imagine if
instead of starting with a 9 by 9 pixel
image we had started with a 9,000 by
9000 pixel image shrinking it is
convenient for working with it makes it
smaller the other thing it does is
pooling doesn't care where in that
window that maximum value occurs so that
makes it a little less sensitive to
position and the way this plays out is
that if you're looking for a particular
feature in an image it can be a little
to the left a little to the right
maybe a little rotated and it'll still
get picked up so we do max pooling with
all of our stack of filtered images and
get in every case smaller set of
filtered images now that's our second
trick third trick normalization this is
just a step to keep the math from
blowing up and keep it from going to
zero all you do here is it everywhere in
your image that there is a negative
value change it to zero so for instance
if we're looking back at our filtered
image we have these what are called
rectified linear units
that's the little computational unit
that does this but all it does is steps
through every where there's a negative
value change it to zero now their
negative value change it to zero by the
time you're done you have a very similar
looking image except there is no
negative values
they're just zeros and we do this with
all of our images and this becomes
another type of layer so in a rectified
linear unit a stack of images becomes a
stack of images with no negative values
now what's really fun the magic starts
to happen here when we take these layers
convolution layers rectified linear
units and pooling layers and we stack
them up so that the output of one
becomes the input of the next you'll
notice that what goes into each of these
and what comes out of these looks like
an array of pixels or an array of an
array of pixels and because of that we
can stack that nicely we can use the
output of one for the input of the next
and by stacking them we get these
operations building on top of each other
what's more we can repeat the stacks we
can do deep stacking you can imagine
making a sandwich that is not just one
patty in one slice of cheese and one
lettuce in one tomato but a whole bunch
of let layers double Tripper triple
quadruple Decker's as many times as you
want each time the image gets more
filtered as it goes through convolution
layers and it gets smaller as it goes to
pooling layers now the final layer in
our toolbox it's called a fully
connected layer here every value it's a
vote on what the answer is going to be
so we take our now much filtered and
much reduced in size stack of images we
break them out we just rearrange and put
them into a single list because it's
easier to visualize that way and then
each of those connects to one of our
answers that we're going to vote for
when we feed this in X there will be
certain values here that tend to be high
they tend to predict very strongly this
is going to be an X they get a lot of
vote for the x outcome similarly when we
feed in a
sure of an o2 our convolutional neural
network there are certain values here at
the end that tend to be very high and
tend to predict strongly when we're
going to have an O at the end so they
get a lot of weight a strong vote for
the O category now when we get a new
input and we don't know what it is and
we want to decide the way this works is
the input goes through all of our
convolutional our rectified linear unit
our pooling layers and comes out to the
end here we get a series of votes and
then based on the weights that each
value gets to vote with we get a nice
average of out at the end in this case
there's this particular set of inputs
votes for an X with a strength of 0.92
and an O with the strength of 0.5 one so
here definitely X is the winner and so
the neural network would categorize this
input as an X so in a fully connected
layer a list of feature values becomes a
list of votes now again what's cool here
is that a list of votes looks a whole
lot like a list of feature values so you
can use the output of one for the input
of the next and so you can have
intermediate categories that aren't your
final votes or sometimes these are
called hidden units in a neural network
and you can stack as many of these
together as you want also but in the end
they all end up voting for an X or an O
and whoever gets the most votes wins so
if we put this all together then a
two-dimensional array of pixels in
results in a set of votes for a category
out at the far end so there are some
things that we have glossed over here
you might be asking yourself where all
of the magic numbers come from things
that I pulled out of thin air include
the features in the convolutional layers
those convene
three pixel by three pixel diagonal
lines and the X also the voting weights
in the fully connected layers I really
waved my hands about how those are
obtained in all these cases the answer
is the same there is a trick called back
propagation all of these are learned you
don't have to know them you don't have
to guess them the deep neural network
does this on its own so the underlying
principle behind back propagation is
that the error in the final answer is
used to determine how much the network
adjusts and changes so in this case if
we knew we were putting in an X and we
got 0.92 vote for an X and that would be
a error of 0.08 and we got a point five
one vote for oh we know that that would
be an error of 0.49 actually an error of
0.5 one because it should be zero then
if we add all that up we get an error of
what should be 0.5 nine so what happens
with this error signal is it helps drive
a process called gradient descent if
there is another bit of something that
is pretty special sauce to deep neural
networks it is the ability to do
gradient descent so for each of these
magic numbers each of the feature pixels
each voting weight they're adjusted up
and down by a very small amount to see
how the error changes the amount that
they're adjusted is determined by how
big the error is large error they're
adjusted a lot small error just a tiny
bit no error they're not adjusted at all
you have the right answer stop messing
with it as they're adjusted you can
think about as sliding a ball slightly
to the left and slightly to the right on
a hill you want to find the direction
where it goes downhill I'm going to go
down that slope down that gradient to
find the very bottom
because the bottom is where you have a
very least error that's your happy place
so after sliding it to the left and to
the right you find the down in the
direction and you leave it there doing
that many times over lots of lots of
iterations lots of steps helps all of
these values across all the features and
all of the weights settle in to what's
called a minimum and it ended at that
point the network is performing as well
as it possibly can and adjust any of
those a little bit its behavior it's an
error will go up now there are some
things called hyper parameters and these
are knobs that the designer gets to turn
decisions the designer gets to make
these are not learned automatically in
convolution figuring out how many
features should be used how big those
features should be how many pixels on
the side in the pooling layers choosing
the window size and the window stride
and in fully connected layers choosing
the number of hidden neurons
intermediate neurons all of these things
are decisions that the designer gets to
make right now there are some common and
practices that tend to work better than
others but there is no principled way
there's no hard and fast rules for the
right way to do this and in fact a lot
of the advances in convolutional neural
networks are in getting combinations of
these they're work really well now in
addition to this there are other
decisions the designer gets to make like
how many of each type of layer and in
what order and for those that really
like to go off the rails can we design
new types of layers entirely and slip
them in there and get new fun behaviors
these are all things that people are
playing with to try to eat got more
performance and address stickier
problems with CNN's
now what's really cool about these we've
been talking about images but you can
use any two-dimensional or even for that
matter of three or four dimensional data
but what's important is that in your
data things closer together are more
closely related and things far away what
I mean by that is if you look at an
image two rows of pixels or two columns
of pixels are right next to each other
they're more closely related than rows
or columns that are far away now what
you can do is you can take something
like sound and you can chop it up into
little time steps and for each piece of
time that the time step right before and
right after is more closely related than
time steps that are far away and the
order matters you can also chop it up
into different frequency bands bass
mid-range treble you can slice it a
whole lot more finely than that
and again those frequency bands are the
ones closer together and we're closely
related and you can't rearrange them the
order matters once you do this with
sound it looks like a picture it looks
like an image and you can use convert
convolutional neural networks with them
you can do something similar with text
where the position in the sentence
becomes the column and the row is words
in a dictionary in this case it's hard
to argue whether order matters that
order matters it's hard to argue that
words in the dictionary are that's are
more closely related than others in all
cases and so the trick here is to take a
window that spans the entire column top
to bottom and then slide it left to
right that way it captures all of the
words but it only captures a few
positions in the sentence at a time
now the other side of this limitation of
convolutional neural networks is that
they're really designed to capture local
spatial patterns spatial in the sense of
things that are next together and next
to each other matter quite a bit so if
the data can't be made to look like an
image then they're not as useful so an
example of this is say some customer
data if I have each row it's a separate
customer each column is a separate piece
of information about that customer such
as their name their address what they
bought what websites they visited then
this doesn't so much look like a picture
I can take and rearrange those columns
and rearrange those rows and this still
means the same thing and still equally
easy to interpret if I were to take an
image and rearrange the columns and
rearrange the rows it would result in a
scramble of pixels and it would be
difficult or impossible to say what the
image was often there I would lose a lot
of information so as a rule of thumb if
your data is just as useful after
swapping out any of the columns for each
other then you can't use convolutional
neural networks so the take-home is a
convolutional neural networks are great
at finding patterns and using them to
classify the images if you can make your
problem look like finding cats on the
internet then there are a huge asset
applications of machine learning have
gotten a lot of traction in the last few
years there's a couple of big categories
that have had wins one is identifying
pictures the equivalent of finding cats
on the Internet and any problem that can
be made to look like that and the other
is sequence to sequence translation
this can be speech to text or one
language to another most of the former
are done with convolutional neural
networks
the latter are done with recurrent
neural networks particularly long
short-term memory to give an example of
how long short-term memory works we will
consider the question of what's for
dinner let's say for a minute that you
are a very lucky apartment dweller and
you have a flatmate who loves to cook
dinner every night he cooks one of three
things
sushi waffles or pizza and you would
like to be able to predict what you're
gonna have on a given night so you can
plan the rest of your days eating
accordingly in order to predict what
you're going to have for dinner you set
up a neural network the inputs to this
neural network are a bunch of items like
the day of the week the month of the
year whether or not your flatmate was in
a late meeting variables that might
reasonably affect what you're going to
have for dinner now if you're new to
neural networks I highly recommend you
take a minute and stop to watch the how
neural networks work tutorial there's a
link down in the comments section if
you'd rather not do that right now and
you're still not familiar with neural
networks you can think of them as a
voting process and so in the neural
network that you set up there's a
complicated voting process and all of
the inputs like day of the week and
month of the year go into it and then
you train it on your history of what
you've had for dinner and you learn how
to predict what's going to be for dinner
tonight the trouble is that your network
doesn't work very well
despite carefully choosing your inputs
and training it thoroughly you still
can't get much better than chance
predictions on dinner as is often the
case with complicated machine learning
problems it's useful to take a step back
and just look at the data and when you
do that you notice a pattern your
flatmate makes pizza then sushi then
waffles then pizza again in a cycle it
doesn't depend on the day of the week or
anything else it's an irregular cycle so
knowing this we can make a new neural
network
in our new one the only inputs that
matter are what we had for dinner
yesterday so if we know if we had pizza
for dinner yesterday it'll be sushi
tonight
sushi yesterday waffles tonight and
waffles yesterday Pizza tonight
it becomes a very simple voting process
and and it's right all the time because
your flatmate is incredibly consistent
now if you happen to be gone on a given
night let's say yesterday you were out
you don't know what was for dinner
yesterday
you can still predict what's going to be
for dinner tonight by thinking back to
days ago think what was for dinner then
so what would be predicted for you last
night and then you can use that
prediction in turn to make a prediction
for tonight so we make use of not only
our actual information from yesterday
but also what our prediction was
yesterday so at this point it's helpful
to take a little detour and talk about
vectors a vector is just a fancy word
for a list of numbers if I wanted to
describe the weather to you for a given
day I could say high is 76 degrees
Fahrenheit the low is 43 the winds 13
miles an hour there's going to be a
quarter inch of rain and the relative
humidities 83% that's all the vector is
the reason that it's useful is vectors
lists of numbers are computers native
language if you want to get something
into a format that it's natural for a
computer to compute to do operations on
to do statistical machine learning lists
of numbers are the way to go
everything gets reduced to a list of
numbers before it goes through an
algorithm we can also have a vector for
statements like it's Tuesday's in order
to encode this kind of information what
we do is we make a list of all the
possible values it could have in this
case all the days of the week and we
assign a number to each and then we go
through and set them all equal to zero
except for the one that is true right
now this format is called one hot
encoding and it's very common to see
long vector of zero
with just one element being one it seems
inefficient but for a computer this is a
lot easier way to ingest that
information so we can make a one hot
vector for our prediction for dinner
tonight we said everything equal to zero
except for the dinner item that we
predict so in this case we'll be
predicting sushi now we can group
together our we can group together our
inputs and outputs into vectors separate
lists of numbers and it becomes a useful
shorthand for describing this neural
network so we can have our dinner
yesterday vector our predictions for
yesterday vector and our prediction for
today vector and the neural network is
just connections between every element
in each of those input vectors to every
element in the output vector and to
complete our picture we can show how the
prediction for today will get recycled
the dotted line there means hold on to
it for a day and then reuse it tomorrow
and it becomes our yesterday's
predictions tomorrow now we can see how
if we were lacking some information
let's say we were out of town for two
weeks we can still make a good guess
about what's going to be for dinner
tonight we just ignore the new
information part and we can unwrap or
unwind this vector in time until we do
have some information to base it on and
then just play it forward and when it's
unwrapped it looks like this and we can
go back as far as we need to and see
what was for dinner and then just trace
it forward and play out our menu over
the last two weeks until we find out
what's for dinner tonight
so this is a nice simple example that
showed recurrent neural networks now to
show how they don't need all of our
needs we're gonna write a children's
book
it'll have sentences of the format Doug
saw Jane period Jane saw spot period
spot saw Doug period and so on so our
dictionary is small just the words Doug
spot saw and a period and the task of
the neural network has to put these
together in the right order to make a
good children's book so to do this we
replace our food vectors with our
dictionary vectors here again it's just
a list of numbers representing each of
the words so for instance if doug was
the most recent word that i saw my new
information vector would be all zeros
except for a one in the doug position
and we similarly can represent our
predictions and our predictions from
yesterday
now after training this neural network
and teaching it what to do we would
expect to see certain patterns for
instance any time a name comes up jane
doug or spot we would expect that to
vote heavily for the word saw or for a
period because those are the two words
in our dictionary that can follow a name
similarly if we had predicted a name on
the previous time step we would expect
those to vote also for the word soft or
for a period and then by a similar
method any time we come across the word
saw or a period we know that a name has
to come after that so it will learn to
vote very strongly for a name jane doug
or spot so in this form in this
formulation we have a recurrent neural
network for simplicity I'll take the
vectors and the weights and collapse
them down to that little symbol with the
dots and the arrows the dots and the
lines connecting them and there's one
more symbol we haven't talked about yet
this is a squashing function and it just
helps the network to behave how it works
is you take all of your votes coming out
and you subject them to this squashing
function for instance if something
received a total vote of 0.5 you draw a
vertical line up where it crosses the
function you draw horizontal
line over to the y-axis and there is
your squashed version out for small
numbers the squashed version is pretty
close to the original version but as
your number gets larger the number that
comes out is closer and closer to one
and similarly if you put in a big
negative number then what you'll get out
will be very close to minus one no
matter what you put in what comes out is
between minus one and one so this is
really helpful when you have a loop like
this where the same values get processed
again and again day after day it is
possible you can imagine if in the
course of that processing say something
got voted for twice it got multiplied by
two
in that case it would get twice as big
every time and very soon blow up to be
astronomical by ensuring that it's
always less than one but more than minus
one you can multiply it as many times as
you want you can go through that loop
and it won't explode in a feedback loop
this is an example of negative feedback
or attenuating feedback so you may have
noticed our neural network in his
current state is subject to some
mistakes we could get a sentence for
instance of the form Doug saw Doug
period because Doug strongly votes for
the word saw which in turn strongly
votes for uh name any name which could
be Doug similarly we could get something
like Doug saw Jayne saucepot saw Doug
because each of our predictions only
looks back one time step it has very
short term memory then it doesn't use
the information from further back and
it's subject to these types of mistakes
in order to overcome this we take our
recurrent neural network and we expand
it and we add some more pieces to it the
critical part that we add to the middle
here is memory we want to be able to
remember what happened many times steps
ago so in order to
how this works I'll have to describe a
few new symbols that we've introduced
here one is another squashing function
this one with a flat bottom one is an X
in a circle and one is a cross in a
circle so the cross in a circle is
element by element addition the way it
works is you start with two vectors of
equal size and you go down each one you
add the first element of one vector to
the first element of another vector and
then the total goes into the first
element of the output vector so 3 plus 6
equals 9 then you go to the next element
4 plus 7 equals 11 and so your output
vector is the same size of each of your
input vectors just a list of numbers
same length but it's the sum element by
element of the two and very closely
related to this you've probably guessed
the X in the circle is element by
element multiplication it's just like
addition except instead of adding you
multiply for instance 3 times 6 gives
you a first element of 18 4 times 7 gets
you 28 again the output vector is the
same size of each of the input vectors
now element wise multiplication lets you
do something pretty cool you imagine
that you have a signal and it's like a
bunch of pipes and they have a certain
amount of water trying to flow down them
in this case we'll just assign the
number to that of 0.8 it's like a signal
now on each of those pipes we have a
faucet and we can open it all the way
close it all the way or keep it
somewhere in the middle to either let
that signal come through or block it so
in this case an open gate an open faucet
would be a 1 and a closed faucet would
be a 0 and the way this works with
element wise multiplication we get 0.8
times 1 equals 0.8 that signal passed
right through into the output vector but
the last element 0.8 times zero equals
zero that's signal the original signal
was effectively blocked and then with
the gating value of 0.5 the signal was
passed through but it's smaller it's
attenuated so gating lets us control
what passes through and what gets
blocked which is really useful now in
order to do gating it's nice to have a
value that you know is always between 0
and 1 so we introduce another squashing
function this will represent with a
circle with a flat bottom and this is
it's called the logistic function it's
very similar to the other squashing
function the hyperbolic tangent except
that it just goes between 0 and 1
instead of minus 1 and 1 now when we
introduce all of these together what we
get we still have the combination of our
previous predictions and our new
information those vectors get passed and
we make predictions based on them those
predictions get passed through but the
other thing that happens is a copy of
those predictions is held onto for the
next time step the next pass through the
network and some of them here is a gate
right here some of them are forgotten
some of them are remembered the ones
that are remembered are added back into
the prediction so now we have not just
prediction but our predictions plus the
memories that we've accumulated and that
we haven't chosen to forget yet now
there's an entirely separate neural
network here that learns when to forget
what based on what we're seeing right
now what do we want to remember what do
we want to forget so you can see this is
powerful this let us hold on to things
for as long as we want now you've
probably noticed though when we are
combining our predictions with our
memories we may not necessarily want to
release all of those
memories out as new predictions each
time so we want a little filter to keep
our memories inside and let our
predictions get out and that's we add
another gate for that to do selection it
has its own neural network so its own
voting process so that our new
information and our previous predictions
can be used to vote on what all the
gates should be what should be kept
internal and what should be released as
a prediction we've also introduced
another squashing function here since we
do an addition here it's possible that
things could become greater than 1 or
smaller than minus 1 so we just squash
it to be careful to make sure it never
gets out of control
and now when we bring in new predictions
we make a lot of possibilities and then
we collect those with memory over time
and of all of those possible predictions
at each time step we select just a few
to release as the prediction for that
moment each of these things when to
forget and when to let things out of our
memory are learned by their own neural
networks and the only other piece we
need to add to complete our picture here
is yet another set of gates this lets us
actually ignore possible predictions
possibilities as they come in this is an
attention mechanism it lets things that
aren't immediately relevant be set aside
so they don't cloud the predictions in
memory going forward it has its own
neural network and its own logistic
squashing function and its own gating
activity right here now long short-term
memory has a lot of pieces a lot of bits
that work together and it's a little
much to wrap your head around it all at
once so what we'll do is take a very
simple example and step through it just
to illustrate how a couple of these
pieces work
it's admittedly an overly simplistic
example and feel free to poke holes at
it later when you get to that point then
you know you're ready to move on to the
next level
material so we are now in the process of
writing our children's book and for the
purposes of demonstration we'll assume
that this LS TM has been trained on our
children's books examples that we want
to mimic and all of the appropriate
votes and weights in those neural
networks have been learned now we'll
show it in action so so far our story so
far is Jane saw spot period Doug
so Doug is the most recent word that's
occurred in our story and also not
surprisingly for this time step the
names Doug Jane and spot were all
predicted as viable options this makes
sense we had just wrapped up a sentence
with a period the new sentence can start
with any name so these are all great
predictions so we have our new
information which is the word Doug we
have our recent prediction which is Doug
Jane and spot and we passed these two
vectors together to all four of our
neural networks which are learning to
make predictions to do it Naurang to do
forgetting and to do selection so the
first one of these make some predictions
given that the word Doug just occurred
this has learned that the word saw is a
great guess to make for a next word but
it's also learned that having seen the
word Doug that it should not see the
word Doug again very soon seeing the
word Doug at the beginning of a sentence
so it makes a positive prediction for
saw and a negative prediction for Doug
it says I do not expect to see dog in
the near future so that's why Doug is in
black so this example is so simple we
don't need to focus on attention or
ignoring so we'll skip over it for now
and this prediction of saw not Doug is
passed forward and again for the
purposes of simplicity let's say there's
no memory at the
so so and Doug get passed forward and
then the selection mechanism here has
learned that when the most recent word
was a name then what comes next is
either going to be the word saw or a
period so it blocks any other names from
coming out so the fact that there's a
vote for not Doug gets blocked here and
the word saw gets sent out as the
prediction for the next time step so we
take a step forward in time now the word
saw is our most recent word and our most
recent prediction they get passed
forward to all of these neural networks
and we get a new set of predictions
because the word saw just occurred we
now predict that the words Doug Jane or
spot might come next will pass over
ignoring and attention and this example
and we'll take those predictions forward
now the other thing that happened is our
previous set of possibilities the word
saw and not Doug that we were
maintaining internally get passed to a
forgetting gate now the forgetting gate
says hey my last word that came that
occurred was the word saw based on my
past experience then I freakin forget
about you know I know that it occurred I
can forget that it happened but I want
to keep any predictions having to do
with names so it forgets saw holds on to
the vote for not Doug
and now at this element element by
element addition we have a positive vote
for Doug a negative vote for Doug and so
they cancel each other out so now we
just have votes for Jane and spot those
get passed forward our selection gate it
knows that the word saw just occurred
and based on experience a name will
happen next and so it passes through
these predictions for names and for the
next time step then we get predictions
of only Jane and spot not Doug
this avoids the Doug saw Doug period
type of error and the other errors that
we saw what this shows is that long
short-term memory can look back to three
many time steps and use that information
to make good predictions about what's
going to happen next now to be fair to
vanilla recurrent neural networks they
can actually look back several time
steps as well but not very many LS TM
can look back many time steps and has
shown that successfully this is really
useful in some surprisingly practical
applications if I have text in one
language and I want to translate it to
text to another language
LS TMS worked very well even though
translation is not a word to word
process it's a phrase to phrase or even
in some cases a sentence to sentence
process LST MS are able to represent
those grammar structures that are
specific to each language and what it
looks like is that they find the
higher-level idea and translate it from
one mode of expression to another just
using the bits and pieces that we just
walked through another thing that they
do well is translating speech to text
speech is just some signals that vary in
time it takes them and uses that then to
predict what text what word is being
spoken and it can use the history the
recent history of words to make a better
guess for what's going to come next
LS TMS are a great fit for any
information that's embedded in time
audio video on my favorite application
of all of course is robotics robotics is
nothing more than an agent taking in
information from a set of sensors and
then based on that information making a
decision
and carrying out an action it's
inherently sequential and actions taken
now can influence what is sensed and
what should be done many times steps
down the line if you're curious what
lsdm s look like in math this is it this
is lifted straight from the Wikipedia
page I won't step through it but it's
encouraging that something that looks so
complex expressed mathematically can
actually makes a fairly straightforward
picture and story and if you'd like to
dig into it more I encourage you to go
to the Wikipedia page also there are a
collection of really good tutorials and
discussions other ways of explaining LSD
ms that you may find helpful as well
I'd also strongly encourage you to visit
hundred Carpathia's blog posts showing
examples of what LST MS can do in text
you can be forgiven if when reading on
the internet you can substitute magic
for deep learning and it fits perfectly
and all of the articles it's hard to
know what it can't do we don't get to
talk about that very much so the goal of
this talk is just to talk about it on a
really simple nuts in this level the
summary or case you want to take a nap
deep learning is not magic but it's
really good at finding patterns so if
this is our brain this is deep learning
an owl can fly a fighter jet can fly but
there are a whole lot of things that an
owl can do and arguably it's a much more
complex thing although what the fighter
jet does it does really really well so
deep learning is the fighter jet highly
specialized highly engineered we're
today going to talk about the basics the
Wright brother's airplane if you
understand the principles that it works
on then you could see easy to branch out
into the finer engineering details
but there's a whole lot of things that
go on in a fighter jet that we're not
going to talk about in detail but this
is nice we can talk about this at a
comfortable level this is a neuron like
all neurons it's got a big body in the
middle long tail and some arms that
branch off here is an artist conception
of a neural network or a bunch of
neurons again big body long tails
arms this is an actual picture of
neurons into some brain tissue here the
bodies look like dots or blobs you can
see long tails some of which branch and
the arms are pretty much invisible and
again picture of some brain tissue here
the neurons are small dots so you can
barely see any of the tails at all this
is just to give you a sense of how
tightly these things are packed together
and how many of them there are big
numbers with lots of zeros and the crazy
part is that a lot of them are connected
to many more of their neighbors this is
one of our very first pictures of a
neuron Santiago armonica hulk found a
stain he could introduce into a cell
turn the whole thing dark under his
nineteenth-century
light microscope was able to see this
and then draw it with a pen and paper
this is old-school well you see here
though bodies long tails lots of arms
these have we're going to turn it upside
down because that's how they're
typically represented in neural networks
and these pieces actually have names the
bodies are called the soma the long
tails are called axons and they aren't
to help dendrites we're going to draw a
cartoon version of them this is what
they look like in in PowerPoint
now the way that neurons work is a a
dendrite you can think of it as feelers
or whiskers and they look for electrical
activity they pick it up and send it to
the body the soma takes this and adds it
together and accumulates it and then
depending on how fast it's accumulating
it it will activate the axon and send
that signal along down the tail some
more dendrite activity there is the more
axonal activity there is and if you get
all of the dendrites really firing and
that axon is just as active as it can
possibly be in a very simplistic way a
neuron adds things up now a synapse is
where the axon from one neuron touches
the dendrite of another it's an artist
conception of it you can see in Ramon
eco-house drawings these little nubs or
buttons are actually called butonce on
the dendrites and these are sites where
the axon of another neuron touches them
so you can imagine there's a little
connection there will represent that
connection by a circle and the diameter
of that circle is the strength of that
connection big circle strong connection
and it can connect strongly or weakly or
somewhere in between we can put a number
on this connection between 0 and 1 so a
medium connection we'll call it a point
6 when the axon of the input neuron the
upstream neuron is active then it
activates the dendrite of the output
neuron it passes that on with a modest
strength if that connection is strong
then it passes the signal on very
strongly that connection is a 1 then
when the axon is active the next
dendrite is very active likewise if that
connection is very weak say a point -
and when the axon is active the dendrite
of the output neuron is only weakly
activated no connection at all is a 0
now this starts to get interesting
because many different input neurons can
connect the dendrites of a single output
neuron and each connection has its own
strengths we can redraw this by taking
out all of the parallel dendrites and
just drawing each axon and the single
dendrite that it connects to and the
connection strength represented like
this with the dots we can substitute in
numbers for that the weights
although most often oh we can also
separate substitute in line thicknesses
to show how strongly these things are
connected most of the time neural
networks are drawn like this and this is
what we have we went from the super
complex slice of brain tissue with many
subtleties in its operation and
interconnection to a nice circle stick
diagram where each one of those sticks
represents a weight in its current form
it can still do some pretty cool things
the input neurons info neurons can
connect to many output neurons so
actually what you get here is many
inputs many outputs and the connection
between each is distinct and has its own
weight this is amazing for making pretty
pictures it's also great for
representing combinations of things and
the way this is done let's say you have
five inputs labeled ABCDE in this case
this output neuron has a strong
connection to a C he very weak
connections to B and D that means when
the a C and E input neurons are active
all together that really strongly
activates the output neuron B and D
don't matter because they only connect
weakly so a way to think about this
output neuron is in terms of the inputs
that strongly activate it so we call
this the AC II neuron and here we have
an atomic example
what happens here this output neuron
represents a combination of the input
neurons
this is neural networks in a nutshell
you can do this with any kind of input
so you have a really low tech four pixel
camera
each of those four inputs is one of the
pixels upper left lower left upper right
or lower right in this particular neural
network with strong connections to the
upper left and upper right pixel we have
a neuron and output neuron that
represents this bar in the top half of
the image so we can combine letters we
can combine pixels to make small images
if you're doing text processing the
input neurons can represent individual
words so in this case we're pulling
words out of text this output neuron is
strongly connected to the endurance for
eye and ball so we can call it the
eyeball neuron similarly we can have a
sunglasses neuron and input neurons can
collect too many outputs we could have
an eyeglasses neuron just as easily so
going a little deeper into this this is
a somewhat trivial example to show how
these things work in practice so there's
a guy at the shwarma place and makes
formal like nobody else so you want to
make sure and go when he's working there
and taking a step back we actually have
some domain knowledge here we know he's
got two schedules working in the morning
often evening and often the morning
working in the evening now if we were to
instrument this with sensors we would
have be working in the morning off in
the morning working in the evening often
to evening and it might be useful to
represent his working patterns in terms
of a couple of output neurons they
combine those so this is the network
that we would expect to end up with
working in the morning off in the
evening is one pattern off in the
morning working in the evening is the
other pattern and you can see based on
their connection strengths how they
combine those inputs here would be the
weights associated with those now the
question is how do we learn this if we
have to go in and fill it all in by hand
we haven't learned anything that's just
a fancier way of programming and a lot
of hard work especially if you're
dealing with many millions of input
neurons so you want to learn this
automatically so to start with might be
a little counterintuitive we created our
neural network we have already put
neurons all we choose is the number of
output neurons in this case we'll choose
two because we happen to know we're
learning two patterns and then we
randomly assign weights randomly number
generate numbers for each of these it's
a neural network this completely you
roll the dice you throw the sticks and
whatever falls out that's what you start
with and then we start to gather data we
go stand on the other side of the street
and we observe that this swarm a guy on
this particular day worked in the
morning and then went home did not work
in the evening that means this input is
active we'll say it's at a level one off
in the morning is at a level zero
because we didn't observe it working in
the morning is at zero and off and the
evening is out of one because we
observed that too so the next step is
for each of the output neurons we
calculate the activity so in this case a
appropriately simple way to do this is
just take the average of the inputs so
here this weight is 0.3 and this way it
is 0.1 so the average of those is 0.2
these neurons don't contribute anything
because those inputs aren't active
similarly we can take the weight between
this input and that out
point eight in point four the average of
those is point six the up and run on the
right has a higher activity that's the
one we care about we ignore all the
others there's a million other as we
ignore the rest and focus on this one
for this time step first thing we figure
out is how wrong is it well if it was
perfect
our neural network is perfect that would
have an activity of one it would be
perfectly aligned with our inputs but it
only has an activity of 0.6 so error is
0.4 the bigger that error is that's a
signal for how much we need to adjust
our weights when that error gets very
small it means that the weights really
represent what's going on
and we don't need to make any more
changes now the trick here gradient
descent if there is an element of magic
in deep learning its gradient descent
what you do is you go through and adjust
each of these ways all through you
adjust it a little bit up and a little
bit down and see which way decreases the
error the idea a concept in gradient
descent is weight is a quantity that you
can shift a little bit side to side as
you do this error will change in think
of it as taking this ball if you shift
it a little bit to the left it has to
climb the hill if you shift it a little
to the right it has to fall down the
hill and you like the direction you
choose the direction in which it gets
lower you want to bring that error down
as low as it can get and you take small
incremental steps to keep everything
numerically stable so we go through and
we do these for all of the neurons sorry
for all of the weights that detached
input neurons to our outlet we find that
yes we want to increase this one because
these aren't active we actually have a
bias toward low weights so it doesn't
hurt to decrease these so we'll go ahead
and decrease that weight decrease
increase that when we do that sure
enough our new activity is 7 and so our
arrow and from 2.4 to 0.3 it's a little
bit better at representing what we saw
so that was one data point we go back
and we do the same thing the next day it
just so happens that this day he's off
in the morning working in the evening we
adjust the weights we do that day after
day after day and eventually the weights
will stop changing or they'll slow down
changing quite a bit they'll get stable
and we get the system of weights that we
originally saw because we had knowledge
of the problem so this is the Wright
brother's airplane version of how
trading by back propagation using
gradient descent works back propagation
is a very specific way to do this that
is computationally cheap and slick and
fast and you get your your jet engine
instead of the flapping of wings so this
is an underlying mechanism by which it
works so what we just looked at was a
single layer we have inputs we have
outputs every output is a combination of
things that were on the previous layer
now there is no reason then that we
can't turn around and take that output
layer and make it inputs for the next
layer and do that again
and again if a network has more than
three layers or so we call it deep some
have more than 12 in some recent
research at Microsoft there are deep
neural networks would lay at more than
$1,000 there is no theoretical reason to
limit the number of layers that you have
it just depends on the specifics of your
problem now what does deep get you
why is deep special if your input
neurons are say letters in the alphabet
your first layer outputs sorry this is a
deep neural network with all of the
connections emitted for clarity so these
are your inputs
first layer of outputs they're
combinations of those letters each level
you go up you get combinations of what
happened the level before so by the time
you get to your second level of outputs
you're getting perhaps words in the
English language that's what you're
training on the layer above that you get
combinations of words short phrases and
so forth and you can do this as deep as
you like so there's a variety of things
you can learn with deep neural networks
very popular one is images if you take
as your inputs pixels and show instead
of looking at swarm a guys schedule
you're looking at individual pictures
that's your training data set what you
start to learn after a while is these
little representations of short lines
and dot's and captures these are the
primitives of an image if you train on
image of faces then your first layer
output start your second layer outputs
start to look like eyes noses and mouths
and chins and your third layer out would
start to look clearly recognizable as
faces similarly if you trained on
automobiles their second layer outputs
start to look like wheels and doors and
windows and your third layer output look
like automobiles so that's pretty cool
we didn't have to go in and to twiddle
any of those weights this just learned
that from seeing a bunch of pictures you
can do it on color images too here's an
output of 1/8 some of me output neurons
have an 8 layer neural network and as
you get deeper you can see things that
are clearly recognizable and quite
complex
you get spiders and rocking chairs and
sailing and ships and teddy bears you
can also plug information in about music
artists so here's some research where
output neurons were learned based on
information about artists and then their
representation was plotted based on how
some
they were enough and they goes up with
neurons and so we see things like Kelly
Clarkson and Beyonce are similar over
here which is also not too far from
Taylor Swift and Avril Lavigne whereas
if we go up here we get Weezer Black
Keys Modest Mouse presidents of the
United States of America all in the same
neighborhood this is a network that
didn't know anything still doesn't know
anything about music
but because of the data that it gets on
the input neurons it's able to group
these things appropriately it finds
patterns and then finds things that most
closely fits those patterns turns out
you can take Atari 2600 games take the
pixel representations feed those in as
input neurons learn some fun features
and then pair it with something else
called reinforcement learning that
learns appropriate actions when you do
this for a certain class of games that
can learn to play them far better than
any human player ever has and it turns
out that you can take a robot and let it
watch youtube videos about how to cook
and it loose uses a pair of deep neural
networks one to interpret the video one
to learn to understand its own movements
and then uses those pairs that with some
other execution software to cook based
on the video representations that it's
seen so while it's not magic it's pretty
cool you can do something so as you're
going through reading literature reading
the popular articles about this you can
kind of play bingo there are some buzz
words and the popular algorithms you can
think of a lot of these as the you know
model numbers for the various fighter
jets that are out there but when you see
any of these terms if you like you can
mentally do the substitution of deep
learning and apply what you know about
the Wright brother's airplane and most
of it will still be accurate the bottom
line it's good at learning patterns it
doesn't do anything but it's pretty good
at learning patterns I'm
to get to talk about two of my favorite
topics at once machine intelligence and
robots they go together pretty well but
they're not the same thing you can
definitely have one without the other
first some disclaimers I'm not going to
give you the answer to human level
intelligence I would if I had it but I
don't next these are my own personal
opinions they're definitely not those of
any current or former employer and they
don't reflect those of many experts in
the field take them with a huge grain of
salt if they are useful you're welcome
to them and if they're not please
discard them also this story that I'm
going to tell you is not rigorous it
doesn't have n equations it's conceptual
and I just intended to start a
discussion and foster ideas throughout
this presentation we'll be talking about
intelligence the working and definition
that I propose is that it's a
combination of how much one can do and
how well one can do it
notionally you could be extremely good
at only one thing and not be that
intelligent also you could do many
things but do them all very poorly and
also not be that intelligent
intelligence is the combination of being
able to do many things and to do them
well this is a functional definition of
intelligence there are many other
potential definitions some of them can
be measured experimentally and some
can't this particular definition has the
advantage that if we wanted to reduce it
down to a measurable set of tasks we
could because it is at least in theory
observable this allows us to have a
scientific discussion about machine
level intelligence
it lets us form hypotheses that we can
potentially falsify and it lets us
compare the relative intelligence of two
separate agents in short it's practical
and useful undoubtedly some will find it
philosophically unsatisfying that's a
separate conversation
but one that I would be happy to have in
another forum using fake math we can say
that intelligence equals performance
times generality it's only fake because
we haven't defined performance or
generality yet but assuming we do you
can imagine plotting them and putting
them on a set of axes like this although
we haven't defined it quantitatively for
human performance what I would like to
propose is that human performance is the
level at which a human expert can do
something this can be measured in lots
of different ways it can be error rates
or the time required to execute a task
the time required to learn a task the
number of demonstrations required before
one learns a task the amount of energy
expended when one performs a task the
subjective judgment of performance from
a panel of human judges the speed that
someone does something there are many
aspects of performance and I'm not going
to try and specify or quantify them all
here I only list them to illustrate that
we are considering performance in a
broad sense
we're considering performance in a broad
sense rather than in a narrow machine
learning accuracy leaderboard sense if
we consider human level performance to
be something of a baseline we can place
it on our x-axis and then chop up the
rest of the axis in equal increments
we'll make this a logarithmic scale to
enable us to compare a very wide range
of performances equal steps along this
axis represent equal multiplicative
factors of change human level generality
is the set of all the tasks that humans
can do and have undertaken these include
things like writing stories cooking pies
building cities gathering and
transmitting information all around the
world and even exploring the origin of
the universe it's a very broad set of
activities we can represent human level
of generality on the y-axis roughly this
is the set of all tasks that a human or
group of humans can do will make the
y-axis logarithmic as well so an equal
interval is a factor of 10 in
performance either multiplied or divided
depending on whether you're moving up or
down so human intelligence can be
notionally represented by the area
that's entailed by this point just want
to point out there's no reason to
believe that machines might not exceed
human performance in some areas humans
have a number of limitations that are
built into the way in which we've
achieved our intelligence through
evolution things that may have been very
useful at one point or may be useful
broadly but now may not be useful in
pushing the limits of intelligence
things like limited attention
instinctive drives how every part of us
fatigues and a host of cognitive biases
all of which put some distance between
us
and perfectly rational or perfectly
efficient or optimal behavior machines
by comparison have a more nurturing
environment in which to take root they
don't have to evolve we're trying
everything we can to encourage them now
you can imagine on the performance and
generality axes another agent that can
do a Lex larger set of tasks than humans
although do them all more poorly than a
human could so it might look like this
the area under that triangle the overall
intelligence would still be comparable
to that of a human so we would call that
human level intelligence also you can
also imagine an agent who can do a
subset of the tasks that humans do but
do them so very much better that the
area under that rectangle is also about
the same as a human's so again human
level intelligence now if we take the
set of all of these agents that have
about the same area under their
intelligence rectangle then we get this
curve representing human level
intelligence any agent who falls along
that curve would be comparable to a
human in the agent down and to the left
of it sub human intelligence and any
agent up and to the right
superhuman intelligence now let's look
at a few agents that you might be
familiar with and see where they fall on
this scheme chest-pain chess-playing
computers have been around for going on
30 years now which is a world-champion
chess-playing computers have been around
for almost 30 years
IBM's deep blue beat Garry Kasparov in
1989 this was a task that people assumed
hue computers would have a very tough
time with it involved planning strategy
thinking mental models of your opponent
it seemed to take in the very peak of
human cognition and its
unlikely that such a thing could be done
by a fancy calculator but it did and now
a chess program running on your phone
can do about the same as deep blue did
the current state of the art is a
program called stockfish which has an e
low rating which is like a chess skill
score of 3447 compare this to the top
human top rated human player of all time
Magnus Carlsen who achieved a 2882 the
program and the human are not even
comparable they're not even close it's
worth noting that stockfish is an
open-source project with code freely
available and has a number of
contributors scattered around the globe
now in terms of generality stockfish
understands the rules of chess and in
fact it understands them very well it
has a bunch of hints and tips and tricks
built in by humans that are specific to
chess it uses a point system to evaluate
pieces based on where they are and what
the stage of the game is it uses a full
table of end games once there are just a
few pieces left on the board the number
of possibilities for how the game will
play out are few enough that they can be
completely enumerated so there's no
search there's no solving that there's
just essentially looking up into a giant
table and figuring out what to do next
they're hand-tuned strategies for each
phase of the game and then what the
computer does is uses tree search to
evaluate future moves each choice of
move is a branch on this tree and it can
look and say for each move what's the
likely outcome for each of those
outcomes what are the possible moves my
opponent can make for each of those
outcomes then what are my possible
responses and by fully going down this
branching tree and looking at all the
possibilities the program can then
figure out what its best choice is now
one of the things that make stockfish so
clever and good at its games it's very
good at pruning this tree and ignoring
moves that are unlikely to lead to any
good end and not exploring them very far
but all told this program is pretty
useless at anything that is not chess it
is the opposite of general so on our
plot we would put chess well above human
level performance but also very low on
the generality axis now compare that to
go also a board game if you're not
familiar with it there are 19 by 19 grid
and opponents take turns placing quite
in black stones the rules are actually
in some ways simpler than chess at each
turn you take a junction on which to
place a stone now the strategy however
some argue is even more complex and more
importantly more subtle it's what is
undoubtedly true is there are more
possible board configurations where
chess has an 8x8 board go has a 19 by 19
board where each piece in chess has a
small prescribed number of motions any
stone and go can be placed on any open
junction so when doing at research the
number of moves explodes much more
quickly than in chess now despite this
two years ago already
alphago a program built by researchers
at deep mind beat Lisa doe a
professional 9dan player professional
9/10 would put him in the all-stars of
the go world a later version alphago
master was clocked with an e low rating
of 4858 compare this to the
highest-rated human player park room one
was rated at 66 69 so not only has go
beaten the best players of the world but
now already by a very healthy margin now
as we mentioned the program understands
the rules ago or knows the rules of go
and use that research to evaluate moves
because there are so many possible board
configurations however it can't memorize
them all so it uses convolutional neural
networks to learn common configurations
and most importantly it can see patterns
that are not exactly repeated but are
similar to things that is seen before
this is an important innovation and
we'll come back to convolutional neural
networks in a few minutes it also uses
reinforcement learning on a library of
human games to learn which moves are
good reinforcement learning and very
straightforward terms is looking at a
configuration an action and the outcome
and learning the pattern for a given
configuration if I take action a good
things happen if I take action B bad
things tend to happen after I learn
those patterns the next time I see
configuration a I can take the action
that leads to good things so using
reinforcement learning on a library of
human games then kind of bootstrapped
alphago and let it learn from the
history of human play and human insights
to get started but like stockfish it's
useless at anything that's not go so
while it has a few tricks that allow it
to be more general it is still very
narrow in its applications so on our
plot we might put it here again far
exceeding human level performance but
still very low on the generality axis
now let's take a jump to a different
category entirely image classification
there is a wonderful data set called
image net which has many thousands of
images classified by hand by humans into
a thousand predefined category
race these categories include household
items cars and doors and chairs includes
animals giraffes rhinoceroses it also
includes for instance many different
species of dog so it's not a trivial
thing to take an image and accurately
categorize it and in fact a typical
human score on this is about 5% error
about one out of every 20 images a human
will classify incorrectly so it's a
tough task in 2011 there was began a
large-scale visual recognition challenge
in which teams got to put together their
algorithms for classifying these images
and in 2011 the very best one got 26
percent error so about 1 in every 4
image was wrongly classified still 3 out
of every 4 was correct which was pretty
amazing performance each year this error
rate decreased by close to 1/2 which is
an amazing rate of progress finally in
2015 the error rate got lower than human
so we had a computer program classifying
images better than a human does now in
2017 one of the more recent competitions
more than half of the teams got fewer
than 5% wrong
so now machines are routinely beating
humans at this task pretty impressive in
terms of generality this task is
definitely harder more general more
challenging than a board game there are
more variations more possibilities and
to get at it it uses convolutional
neural networks which are a deep neural
network architecture specifically
designed for finding patterns in
two-dimensional arrays of data like a
pixels or squares on a chessboard or on
a go board they're very good at finding
patterns that could be visually
represented
this is good but it has been shown to
break easily outside of the set of
images that you train it on to give an
example of this if you look at the
images on the right and the left hand
column we see soap dispensers praying
mantis a poppy these are all images that
were correctly categorized by a
convolutional neural network with the
addition of a little bit of distortion
shown in the middle column which you're
seeing that correctly is just a little
bit of noise but the gray has no change
at all you get the images on the right
visually to us they look identical or
very similar you might be able to see a
little bit of warping and distortion
there but for whatever reason
convolutional neural networks
confidently predicted all of these to be
ostriches so this is not to say that
they are not powerful and good but they
see something different than we are
seeing they are not learning to see in
the same way that we see since then the
fragile nature of convolutional neural
networks has been demonstrated through
other ways in some images changing a
single pixel the right pixel to the
right value can change how that image is
classified others have found that you
don't even have to go into the digital
domain you can take carefully-designed
stickers and to fix them to something
and have that object be confidently
classified as a banana whatever it is
and in my favorite demonstration now
physical plastic turtle was rotated and
from every direction the convolutional
neural network confidently predicted
that it was a turtle then after just
repainting a different pattern not
symbolic or representative of anything
but carefully chosen that same
convolutional neural network categorized
it as a handgun these examples show that
at least as currently
our image classification generality is
not quite where we would like it to be
so definitely higher than human
performance but classifying imagenet is
a much narrower task than it might
appear on the surface so we'll put it
pretty low on the generality axis now
here's a really fun example video game
performance so again the folks at deep
mind put together deep q-learning
or deep reinforcement learning
architecture to play video games we'll
talk about more about what that is in a
second but what they did is they took 49
classic Atari games and let the
algorithm just look at the pixels and
make random moves and the algorithm
didn't know if this was supposed to be a
move left or a move right or a jump or a
shoot it just took moves and then used
reinforcement learning to learn from the
outcome and then learn this pattern of
oh when I see this and I do this either
or something good happens or something
bad happens or something neutral happens
after doing that for long enough it
learned the patterns that let it choose
the right thing to do and in 29 of these
49 games it did at or above human expert
level play and that was super impressive
so this is not just looking at a picture
and saying this is a cat this is looking
at a picture in the moment and saying
for this particular instance the right
thing to do is jump and then by jumping
that changes the image and then having
to respond to the new configuration and
doing that again and again and again and
doing this better than a human now the
other part of this is there were 20
games then at which it did more poorly
than a human so after using
convolutional neural networks to learn
the pixel patterns for which this is
perfectly suited
because the pixels are big and course
there's no noise they don't change the
patterns are clear so what the algorithm
is seeing is very close to what we as
humans see and after unique using
reinforcement learning to learn what
actions to take in each situation 20 of
these games it wasn't able to match
human performance on and the pattern
among those games is they tended to
require longer term planning the one of
them was miss pac-man if you've ever
played that you know you're trying to
eat all the dots and a maze while
avoiding ghosts who are chasing you it
involves planning routes out several
turns ahead anticipating where ghosts
are going to be a lot of things that you
can't get from a single snapshot and
without thinking ahead several steps in
its current state this algorithm didn't
do that and in fact the game that it at
the poorest on it came called
montezuma's revenge required much more
extensive planning going to one location
and grabbing an object so you could go
to another location and open a door and
the computers was not able to make those
connections so we'll add video games to
our plot here again more general than
image classification there's more going
on the task is broader and performance
is about human level now you may notice
a pattern here these fit roughly into a
line or a curve and we'll see this
pattern continue looking at machine
translation taking text and changing it
from one language to another have you
ever gone to an online translator and
typed in a phrase or copied a phrase
from a language you weren't familiar
with to one that you were you will
probably notice that the translation is
surprisingly good at getting some of the
sense which is even five years ago was
complete science fiction to be able to
do this in a reliable way you'll
probably also know to notice that the
result is nothing that a native language
speaker would ever be likely to say
so it's it's okay it's definitely in the
right direction but it's far from
perfect now what's really impressive to
me about this is that the state of the
art and language translation takes over
a hundred languages and instead of
having specific models to translate from
each language to each language all of
these languages are translated to a some
uber intermediate representation which
is then able to be translated back into
any one of these hundred plus languages
so all to all language translator so the
sheer scope of that is really impressive
now in order to do this it uses long
short term memory LS TM which is a
neural network architecture and it
actually uses several deep neural
networks in concert one to carefully
ignore parts of the input one to choose
what to remember one to choose what to
forget one to choose what to pass on
there's quite a bit of computation
involved and this architecture uses
several levels of those even so the the
amount of effort and computing power
thrown at this in general is if we use
one of our metrics as efficiency it's a
little bit could be considered a little
bit of a hit in addition to the
inaccuracies and it is worth noting that
this uses an attention mechanism so I
called out attention earlier as a
possible limitation of human performance
but it also proves to be a really useful
tool when dealing with a massive amount
of information too much to look at in
depth and so by pre filtering and
focusing down on what's most likely to
be helpful than in an algorithm can be
much more efficient in how it handles it
so for machine translations a
amazing performance still short of human
and for the wildly ambitious scope it
gets a little step up on the generality
axis a little bit of a hit on their
performance axis translation is still a
very small part of all the things that
humans do but I would definitely say
this is more general than playing video
games now looking at recommenders so if
you think back to your last experience
with a non time online real online
retailer probably the recommendations
that you got were maybe one in ten was
really really relevant some of the
others were close but near misses and
some of the others were obviously way
out in left field so this is still
pretty good like this is a tough task if
you can imagine like back when there
were video stores going to a video store
with your friend and trying to guess
what your friend even a friend you knew
very well would want to watch on a given
night you know you would be hard-pressed
to do better than like 1 and 3 or 1 & 4
so you know one in ten is not terrible
for just ballpark it's common to assume
among these algorithms that order
doesn't matter so it just looks at
everything you've ever bought did today
yesterday last year and it doesn't think
about how these things are related or
how many you might have or how many you
might need or how something that you
brought previously might be related to
what you might need tomorrow
it just looks at what people have bought
in the past what they bought together
it also doesn't adapt to the fact that
your selections by chain with time so
even if you've bought one jar of
mayonnaise a year ago and then another
one six months ago and another one a few
months ago it might not track the fact
that your preference has changed one of
my favorite examples of these came up
from Jack Rayner Twitter user who said
dear Amazon I bought a toilet seat
because I needed one necessity not to
Iyer I do not collect them I am NOT a
toilet seat addict no matter how
tempting Li you email me I'm not going
to think oh go on then just one more
toilet see I'll treat myself so
recommenders they do okay relative to
humans and i would argue that the
knowledge of the world required to do
really well is pretty deep so we'll
boost it up on the generality scale that
it takes a hit on performance now we
need two robots finally something
physical bumping around in the world
self-driving cars their performance is
impressive take an overall per mile
driven self-driving cars accident rates
are lower than humans and this is pretty
amazing when you consider all of the
things that a car has to deal with
construction pedestrians bicycle riders
changing weather conditions changing
road conditions they're not perfect but
they're surprisingly good now in terms
of generality there are a few things
that make self-driving cars less general
than they might at first appear and in
fact the biggest tricks to making them
successful is to reducing the difficulty
of the task and so reducing the
necessary generality of the solution so
one of the things that happens is
especially during training humans still
have to take over in some challenging
situations when the human gets uneasy or
the car signals it doesn't know what to
do then it falls back to the human and
while driving is still a pretty
complicated task it's still very simple
compared to say walking on rough terrain
while eating a bagel and walking a dog
who's pulling on the leash
there's a lot more to consider there and
it's a lot tougher than a car who is
statically stable on four wheels on a
road that's flat and mostly straight and
mostly marked and where the rules are
well prescribed to further simplify the
task and narrow the scope of what needs
to be learned self-driving cars driving
style tends to be cautious they
definitely do not tend to speed they
tend to not follow closely or turn
aggressively or do anything else that
many human drivers do this is absolutely
good practice and should be lauded and
as a model for all of us to follow but
what that means is that the raw driving
skill required by a self-driving car is
in general less than that required by
human and it should also be noted that
solutions are custom engineered for
driving the selection of sensors the
algorithms used to process them the way
everything's put together is not updated
on the fly
it's gathered evaluated by humans and
then very carefully and deliberately the
heuristics the rules behind how that's
interpreted and processed are then
updated and tested and released again
this makes sense for deploying anything
that is has such a high consequence as a
car but from a machine learning side it
means that the solution is actually not
as general as it seems it's very
specific to a given car with a given set
of sensors and sometimes even to a given
environment some of some self-driving
cars at least early failures had to do
with being deployed in climates that
they weren't familiar with for instance
so until their set of training data
encompasses all of the conditions in
which they will be deployed they will be
even narrower
and human drivers so all these things
considered on the task of driving in
general I chose to rate self-driving
cars at lower performance than human
still its physical interaction and its
interaction with other people in other
cars so it's quite a lot going on and
definitely more complex than machine
translation or any even recommendations
now humanoid robots paint apex of cool
applications if you have not yet done it
get on the internet and search for
robots doing backflips and check it out
when you see something like this it is
easy to make the jump to believe that
robotics has been solved like when a
robot can do physical feats of
acrobatics that I can't do then I mean
it's done I'm ready to call it and yeah
it's just it puts a smile on my face
that I can't wipe off now in terms of
generality do another search for robots
falling down and you'll be treated to a
montage of really humorous shorts of
robots trying to do very simple things
like open a door or lift an empty box or
even stay standing up and they really
struggle with this because the systems
are so complex because the hardware and
the sensors have so much going on and
because most of these are deployed as as
research projects most of these
activities are fairly hard coded and
pretty fragile they make a lot of
assumptions about the nature of the
hardware of what's going on the nature
of the environment and if any of these
assumptions are violated the robots
performance fails
so as a result plotting them here the
generality in the sense that the types
of things that they have experienced
taken together as a whole are now
getting to be a non negligible fraction
of things that humans can do you know
maybe it's point one maybe it's point O
one somewhere in between but an amazing
set of things that can be quite hard but
performance is still sometimes laughably
low compared to human level we can you
know compare you wanted robots as agents
to humans and see that it's much less
more interestingly here our trend now is
quite clear there's a fat line here that
runs roughly parallel offset from the
human level intelligence line as
solutions tend to get higher performance
they also tend to get less general and
vice-versa but it's rare that we get big
steps toward the human intelligence line
now this is this is what I think is cool
this is the whole point of this talk
there is one example that I would like
to show of this before I jump to the
conclusion which is again from deep mind
a program called alpha 0 so alpha 0 is
like alphago accept everything it knows
about go has been taken out it doesn't
know the rules of any game now it just
sees visual patterns tries actions and
learns to see what's successful and
what's not the way it was used is you
can think of a brand-new alpha 0
instance as being an infant in terms of
the gameplay and two alpha zero infants
were created and they started to play
each other one was allowed to learn the
other one was not so the one that
learned gradually cut just a little bit
better stumbling into some good moves
by accident until it became an okay
beginner player of the game then it
cloned itself one of the two learns the
other did not and they played and played
until the one became an intermediate
level player of the game and they
repeated this process of cloning and
playing itself with one learning and the
other not and used its intermediate
steps as scaffolding to get better and
better and it turns out that when using
this approach with go within four hours
it was as good as the best human player
and within eight hours it had beat the
previous best computer its uncle
alphago um because it did not build any
rules of the game it was also able to
learn chess and beat the current best
chess playing program stockfish and
another board game called shogi and beat
the current best shogi playing program
as well
all of which beats humans by a wide
margin so this is cool because it does
both better performance and it's more
general it's not specific to any board
game and presumably if there were other
board games that had two dimensional
grids and a set of rules that was not
wildly wildly different it could learn
to play those as well so generality and
performance so what we have now is a
point that is both farther to the right
higher performance and farther up higher
generality than the original that it was
from so this is a real increase in area
under that rectangle an increase in
intelligence this is the direction that
we want to go so it's worth taking a
step and taking a moment in thinking
about what is it that allowed us to step
in this direction
well alpha zero made
many fewer assumptions about what was
going on and it also was able to
practice as many times as it needed to
through self play in general assumptions
are what prevent generality
they enable performance so if I build in
knowledge of the rules of chess I'm able
to take advantage of those much more
quickly but it also prevents me from
doing anything that's not chess so if I
turn that around making fewer
assumptions I mean it takes me longer to
do something but it means I might be
able to learn to do more things so some
common assumptions sensor information is
noise free we have ideal sensors that
makes sense
if we're playing chess when we sense
that a piece is on a given square we
expect that it will be but if we're
dealing with say a self-driving car
maybe there's a smudge of mud on the
camera maybe the calibration of the
lidar is off a little bit we can't
assume ideal sensors when we're
interacting with the physical world
there are too many things we can't
control for another common assumption is
determinism that's when I take an action
I know that it will have the same
outcome every time again makes great
sense when I have a board game makes
sense if I'm classifying images if I say
an image is an image of a cat I know
that it will be labeled as a cat image
right or wrong however if I'm a humanoid
robot and I make an action to reach for
a doorknob the motor might not perform
the way I expect my feet might slip on
the ground
I might have unanticipated challenges to
my balance the action may not turn out
exactly as I expect and I need to be
able to adapt to this another really
common assumption unimodality all of the
sensors are the same type so this is an
assumption in convolutional neural
networks for instance it's great at
bringing in a two-dimensional array of
information
that is all the same type it's all
pixels where it's all board squares a
general solution needs not to make this
assumption another assumption
stationarity this is a very common one
it's that the world doesn't change that
things that I learned yesterday are
still true today the things I learned
five minutes ago are still true right
now and we have to move make some change
up sorry we have to make some
assumptions about continuity otherwise
what I learned yesterday doesn't do me
any good at all but we also need to
allow for the fact that the world has
changed a little bit
maybe the lubrication and my ankle joint
is a little low so it's going to respond
differently than it did yesterday maybe
there are clouds covering the Sun so the
lighting conditions I learned to operate
in yesterday have changed as well and
I'll need to be able to adapt to that
another common assumption is
independence which is the world is not
changed by what I do to it physical
interaction violates this entirely if I
am a robot operating in a household and
I bump into a chair and I scoot it six
inches sideways then whatever map I've
made of that house will need to be
changed a little bit I have changed it
myself if I pick up a mug and move it
from this table to that table I have
changed the position of that mug that
things that I do
change the world and I need to keep
track of that and any algorithm I use
needs to be able to account for that
another common assumption orga disa t
everything I need to know about how I
operate
I can sense right at this moment this is
a common assumption also known as a
Markov assumption but it's also commonly
broken in physical interaction for
instance if I can sense position that's
great but that doesn't tell me anything
about velocity and sometimes I need to
know velocity to know how to respond to
something
okay another assumption that it's very
common is that the effects of my actions
become apparent very soon this is
something that does not hold true for
instance in chess where the opening move
will affect whether or not I win many
many time steps away there are different
tricks for handling this in chess for
instance assigning point values to
intermediate positions of pieces on the
board but in physical interaction it's
much more difficult to do this to know
that given a set of actions that I take
right now which is most likely to result
in something that's desirable five
minutes from now or a day from now all
of these assumptions are very common in
the algorithms currently being used that
we call AI these algorithms are not
sufficient for achieving human level
intelligence these assumptions will
prevent them from doing that so one
thing that all of these assumptions have
in common is that they do not hold when
you're working with humanoid robotics or
in fact any robot that's physically
interacting with the world so my
proposal is that focusing on interact
physical interaction is a great way to
force us to confront these assumptions
to find out which ones we can bend to
find out which we can avoid all together
and to drive us to create algorithms
that are less fragile and able to
accommodate a much more general set of
tasks that will then take us one step
closer to human level intelligence when
you hear about artificial intelligence
about 1/2 of the time what people are
talking about is convolutional neural
networks understanding how they work is
really
helpful in getting a peek behind the
curtain at the magic of artificial
intelligence so we're gonna walk through
it in some detail convolutional neural
networks takes images and from them they
learn the patterns the building blocks
that make them up so for instance in the
first level of this network you might
learn things like line segments that are
at different angles and then at
subsequent layers those get built into
things like faces or element of cars
depending on the images that you train
the network on you can pair this with
reinforcement learning algorithms to get
algorithms that play video games learn
to play go or even control robots so to
dig into how these work we'll start with
a very simple example much simpler than
all of these a convolutional neural
network that can look at a very small
image and determine whether it's a
picture of an X or an O just two
categories so for example this image on
the left is an 8 by 8 pixel image of an
X we want our network to classify it as
an X similarly with the image of the O
we want the network to classify it as an
O now this is not entirely
straightforward because we also wanted
to handle cases where these inputs are
of different sizes or they're rotated or
they're heavier or they're lighter and
every time we'd like it to give us the
correct answer a human has no problem
looking at these in deciding what to do
but for a computer this is much harder
when trying to decide if these two
things are equal what it does is it goes
through pixel by pixel black pixels
might be a minus 1 white pixels might be
a plus 1 and it'll compare them pixel by
pixel find the ones that match and here
the red pixels are the ones that don't
match so a computer looking at this
would say no these are not the same they
have some matches but they have a lot
that don't match so the way
convolutional neural networks do this
one of the tricks they use is that they
match pieces
of the image so you can look at these
pieces and shift them around a little
bit but as long as the tiny bits still
match then the overall image is still
considered a pretty good match
so these tiny bits might look like this
we'll call them features you can see the
one on the left looks like a diagonal
arm of the X that's leaning left the one
in the middle looks like the center of
the X where it crosses and the one on
the right looks like a diagonal arm
leaning right and you can see how these
different pieces these different
features of the image match different
patches within the overall image so the
math behind finding this match applying
features is called filtering it's pretty
straightforward but it's worth walking
through the way that is done is you
align the feature up on the image patch
you're concerned with multiply pixel by
pixel add up the values and then divide
by the total number of pixels this is
one way to do it here for instance we
start with this feature of the arm of
the X leaning left we align it with this
arm on the image and we start with the
upper left pixel and we multiply both
values one by one equals one now because
we started with the upper left pixel we
can keep track of our answers here
so this pixel when multiplied equals one
the upper center pixel is minus one in
both of the feature and the image so
minus 1 times minus 1 is also equal to 1
so that when you multiply them and you
get a 1 that indicates a perfect and a
strong match and we can continue doing
this throughout the entire feature and
the entire image patch and because they
are a perfect match every single one of
these matches will come back as a 1
so to find the overall match we just add
up all these nine ones divided by the
total number which is nine and we get a
match of one now we can create another
array to keep track of how well the
feature when placed in this position
matched our image so this average values
one we'll put a 1 right there to keep
track of that you can see what it looks
like if we were to move this feature
then and align it to a different patch
so let's say we move it down to the
center of the X and we go pixel by pixel
and find what matches and after a few
pixels we actually find one that doesn't
match we end up with a minus one times a
plus one giving us a minus one back this
indicates a non match of these pixels
and as we go through the rest of the
feature we can see that there are a
couple pixels that don't match so here
when we add these up and divide by nine
we get a number that's less than one
point five five so it indicates a
partial match but not a perfect one it
turns out you can go through and do this
for every possible location in the image
you can chop it up into every possible
image patch compare the feature to each
one and here's what you would get in
this particular case this is what
convolution is it's taking a feature and
at applying it across every possible
patch across a whole image and you can
see here why it's called filtering what
we have is a map of where this feature
matches the image you can see a strong
bunch of Plus Ones on the diagonal line
from the lower right to the upper left
and then lesser values everywhere else
so it's a filtered version of the
original image that shows where the
feature matches you can do this we can
represent this with this notation we
just invented this little convolution
Oppel operator for shorthand
and we can do this with our other
features as well we can see where our
center X matches not surprisingly it
matches strongest in the center of the
image we can see where our leaning right
arm matches and not surprisingly it
matches along this diagonal from the
lower left to the upper right we have
three filtered versions of the original
image so this is what a convolution
layer in a convolutional neural network
does it has a set of features in it and
it can be 3 or 30 or 300 or 3,000 but as
a set of features and it takes the
original image and returns a set of
filtered images one for each of the
features so this is how we'll represent
it
that's the number one ingredient in
convolutional neural networks that is
the magic special sauce the special
trick that gets from a non exact match
and let's the algorithm is able to pull
out ok well it's not a perfect match but
it's still a pretty good match because
it does this convolution and moves the
feature across the image and finds
everywhere that it might match another
piece of this is called pooling so we
took our original image and now we have
a stack of images what this step does is
it shrinks it down a little bit we start
by picking a window size usually 2 or 3
pixels picking a stride usually 2 pixels
has been shown to work well and then
walking this window across the filtered
images and then from each window taking
the maximum value that you see so this
is called max pooling so to see how this
works we start with one of our filtered
images we have our window which is 2
pixels by 2 pixels and within that the
maximum value is 1 so we create another
little array to keep track of all our
result
and we put a 1 in it and then we step it
over by our stride which is 2 pixels
look at the window choose the maximum
value in this case it's 0.33 record it
and go again and we keep doing this
recording the maximum value each time
all the way through the image and when
we're done we have which if you squint
looks like a shrunken version of the
original we still have this strong set
of plus ones on the diagonal from upper
left to lower right and then everywhere
else it's less than that so it maintains
kind of the original signal but shrinks
it down kind of picks off the high
points and this gives us a smaller image
but still similar to the original and we
can just represent it with this little
shrinking arrow we can do this with each
of our filtered images and again you see
that very roughly the pattern of the
original is maintained so in a pooling
layer a stack of images becomes a stack
of smaller images now the last
ingredient we need is normalization so
this keeps the math from breaking by
taking and tweaking these values just a
little bit it takes everything that's
negative and changes it to zero this
keeps things from becoming unmanageably
large as you progress through subsequent
layers this function is called a
rectified linear unit it's a fancy name
for something that just takes anything
that is negative and makes it 0 so 0.77
not negative it doesn't touch it but a
minus point 1 1 it's negative just bumps
it up to 0 and by the time you've gone
through all of your images and done this
all of your pixels and done this this is
what you have so everything that was
negative is now 0 so just a nice little
bit of normalization some conditioning
to keep things numerically well behaved
so a stack of images becomes a stack of
images with no negative values now you
can notice that
the output of one layer looks like the
input to the next there are always
arrays of numbers an image and an array
of number are the same thing they're
interchangeable so you can take the
output of the convolution layer feed it
through the rectified linear units a
feed that through the pooling layer and
when you're done you have something that
has had all of these operations done to
it and in fact you can do this again and
again and this recipe can imagine making
like a scooby-doo sandwich of all of
these different layers again and again
and in different orders and some of the
most successful of convolutional neural
networks are kind of like accidentally
discovered groups of these that just
happen to work really well so they get
used again and again so over time each
convolution layer filters through a
number of features each rectified linear
units everything to be non-negative and
each pooling layer shrinks it so by the
time you're done you get a very tall
stack of filtered images with no
negative values that has been shrunken
down in size now by the time we've gone
through several iterations of this we
take and run it through a fully
connected layer this is more of a
standard neural network where every
input gets connected to everything in
the next layer with a weight every
single value you can think of it as a
voting process so every single pixel
value that's left in these filters
shrunken images gets a vote on what the
answer should be and this vote depends
on how strongly it is tends to predict
an extra know when this pixel is high is
this output usually an X or is it
usually a no so you can see for this
particular input the input was an X
here's what the imaginary involved and
filtered values are
and over time we would learn that these
things that are high when it sees an X
get a strong vote for the X category
similarly if you have an input that's an
O these final pixel values that tend to
be really high when the right answer is
row is o gives a strong vote for the O
category the thicknesses of these lines
represent the weights the strength of
the vote between these pixels and these
answers so now if we get a new input
that we've never seen before these might
be the final pixel values we can use
these votes and do a weighted voting
process for both of these add them up
and in this case you know it's a point 9
to total for X and a point 5 1 total for
0.92 is obviously more than point 5 1 we
declare X the winner so this input will
have been categorized as an X so this is
a fully connected layer so it just takes
a list of feature values in this case
are filtered shrunken pixels and it
becomes a list of votes for each of our
output categories in this case an extern
oh now these can also be stacked you can
have like little they call them hidden
layers but like secret hidden categories
in between here so one votes on the
first layer votes on the first set of
hidden categories and then those vote on
the next layer and so forth until you
get to your final ones well dig into
this more in just a little sec but these
all stack on to the end now to go into
the next level of detail on these neural
networks set aside are X and O detector
for a while there we had 8 by 8 pixel
images so 64 pixels in all consider now
a 2 by 2 pixel image so just a 4 pixel
camera and what we would like to do is
categorize the images that it takes as
either being a solid image all light or
all dark a vertical image
a diagonal image or a horizontal image
now the trick here is that simple rules
can't do it so both of these are
horizontal images but the pixel values
are completely opposite in both of them
so you can't say well if the upper-left
pixel is white and the upper-right pixel
is white then it must be horizontal
because that's violated by the other one
now of course you could do more
complicated rules to do this the point
is that when you go to larger images you
can't make simple rules that capture all
the cases that you want so how do we go
about it we can take these four input
pixels and break them out we call an
input neurons but they just take these
pixels and turn them into a list of
numbers the numbers correspond to the
brightness minus one is black plus one
is white zero is middle gray and
everything else is in between so this
takes this little image and turns it
into a list of numbers that's our input
vector now each of these you can think
of it as having a receptive field this
is an image which makes the value of
this input as high as possible so if you
look at our very top input neuron the
image that makes that number as high as
possible is an upper left pixel that's
white that makes the value of that one
and it doesn't care what the other
pixels are that's why they're chequered
so you can see that each of these has
its own corresponding receptive field
the image that makes the value as high
as it can go now we're gonna build a
neuron so when people talk about
artificial neural networks and a neuron
we are going to build it bit by bit the
first thing you do to build a neuron is
you take all of these inputs you add
them up so in this case this is what
we'd get so the neuron value at this
point is 0.5 now the next thing we do is
we add a weight we mentioned the
weighted voting process before so what
that looks like is each of these inputs
gets assigned a weight between plus and
minus one
and it gets the value gets multiplied by
that weight before it gets added so now
we have a weighted sum of these input
neurons and we will represent this
visually by showing positive weights in
white negative weights in black and the
thickness of the line being
approximately proportional to the weight
and when the weight is zero we'll leave
it out to minimize visual clutter so now
we have a weighted sum of the inputs the
next thing that we need to do is squash
the result so because we're going to do
this a lot of times it's nice if we
always guarantee the answer is between
plus and minus one after each step that
keeps it from growing numerically large
a very convenient function is this
s-shaped so sigmoid squashing function
this particular one is called the
hyperbolic tangent there is confusingly
something else that's called the sigmoid
it's a little bit different but the same
general shape but the characteristic of
this is that you can put in your input
you know draw a vertical line see where
it crosses the curve track that over to
the using a horizontal line to the
y-axis and you can see what the smashed
version the squashed version of your
number is so in this case point five
comes out to be just under point five
point six five comes out to be about 0.6
and as you go up this curve you can see
that no matter how large your number
gets what you get out will never be
greater than one and similarly it'll
never be less than minus one so it takes
this infinitely long number line and
squashes it so that it all falls between
plus and minus one so we apply this
function to the output of our weighted
sum and then we get our final answer so
this weighted sum and squash is almost
always what people are talking about
when they talk about an artificial
neuron now we don't have to do this just
once we can do it as many times as we
want with different weights and this
collection of weighted
summons squash neurons is you can think
of it as a layer loosely inspired by the
biological layers of neurons in the
human cortex so each of these has a
different set of weights here to keep
our picture really simple we'll assume
these weights are either +1 white lines
minus 1 black lines or zero missing
entirely so in this case now we have our
layer of neurons we can see that the
receptive fields have gotten more
complex if you look at the neuron in the
first layer on the top you can see how
it combines the inputs from the
upper-left pixel on the lower left pixel
both of the weights are positive those
lines are white and so what comes out
its receptive field is if both of those
pixels on the left are white then it has
the highest value you can possibly have
if we look at that layer of neurons and
look at the one on the bottom we can see
that it takes its inputs from both of
the pixels on the left I started on the
right but it has a negative weight
collecting connecting it to the lower
right neuron so it's receptive field
it's what maximally activates it is a
white pixel in the upper right and a
black pixel in the lower right now we
can repeat this because the outputs of
those that first layer of neurons looks
a whole lot like our input layer still a
list of numbers between minus 1 and 1
and so we can add additional layers and
we can do this as many times as we want
each time each neuron in one layer is
connected to each neuron and the other
layer by some weight so in this case you
can see how the receptive fields might
get still more complex and now we're
starting to see patterns that look like
the things that were interested in
solids verticals diagonals horizontals
by combining these elements now there's
one more thing that we can do remember
our rectified linear unit
we can have different neurons here and
instead of a weighted summon squash we
can just have something that takes the
input and spits out zero if it's
negative and the original value if it's
positive and so for instance if we have
if we have an input whose receptive
field is the one on the very top and the
second layer all solid white and we
connect it with a positive weight to the
rectified linear unit neuron on top then
of course what would maximize that is
all solid white input but if we look at
the neuron just below that that's
connected to it with a negative weight
then that that flips everything around
and what maximally activates that is an
input that's all solid black now we're
really starting to get the set of
patterns that we can imagine using to
decide what our images so we connect
these again to a final output layer this
output layer is the list of all the
possible answers that we expect to get
out of our classifier originally it was
X's and O's now it's four categories
solid vertical diagonal and horizontal
and each of these inputs into them have
a vote but you can see that very few of
them are connected this network assumes
that most of those votes are zero so to
see how this plays out let's say we
start with an input that looks like the
one on the left with this is obviously a
horizontal image with a dark bar on top
and a white bar on the bottom we
propagate that to the input layer and
then we propagate that to the first
hidden layer and you can see for
instance the neuron on the very top it
combines two input neurons that one is
light and one is dark so you can imagine
it's summing a plus
and a minus one and getting a sum of
zero so that's why it's gray its value
is zero now if you look at the neuron in
the very bottom in that first hidden
layer you can see that it sums also an
input that is negative and one that's
positive but it's connected to one by a
negative weight and the other by a
positive weight so it actually what it
sees it's weighted sum is minus 1 and
minus 1 so what it is getting you can
see is the opposite of its receptive
field so that means it's maximally
activated but negatively so that's why
it's black we move to the next layer and
you can trace these things through so
anything zero plus zero is going to get
you zero if you look at the neuron on
the very bottom of the second hidden
layer you can see that yes it's adding
up a negative and a negative both
connected by positive weight so it's
also going to be negative which makes
sense because you can see that it's
receptive field is the exact opposite of
what the input is right now so it's
maximally activated just negative and
then when we track this to our next
layer you can see that following that
bottom pair of neurons because it's a
negative value because through the
rectified linear unit and becomes 0 so
that's gray but if you look at the very
bottom neuron there it has it's
connected with a negative weight so it
becomes positive so that rectified
linear unit really likes it so it gives
it a maximum value so everything is zero
except for that neuron on the bottom and
then finally what that means is that the
only output that is nonzero is this
horizontal one so this network would
classify the input image as being
horizontal because of this now
there's some magic here where did we get
those weights where did we get the
filters in between this is where we
start to get down to the when we talk
about learning adaptation you know the
learning and machine learning it is all
about optimization these are learned
through a bunch of examples over time so
we're gonna set that aside for just a
minute we'll come back to how those get
learned but we need to talk about
optimization first so consider drinking
tea there is a temperature range where
it is a delightful experience it's warm
and delicious and comfortable if your
tea is too much hotter than that it's
very painful and not good not fun at all
and if your tea is cooler than that its
lukewarm and it's really mad it's really
not worth your time so this area at the
top is the pink this is the best this is
what we're trying to find in
optimization we're just trying to find
the best experience the best performance
now if we want to find that
mathematically the first thing we do is
we flip it upside down just because this
is how optimization problems are
formulated but it's the same type of
thing instead of maximizing tea drinking
pleasure we want to minima minimized tea
drinking suffering we want to find the
bottom of that Valley the lowest
possible suffering there's a few
different ways we could do this the
first is to look at every point on this
curve and just pick the lowest one now
the trick with that is we don't actually
know what this curve is beforehand so in
order to pick the lowest one we have to
do exhaustive search which in this case
would be make a cup of tea have someone
drink it ask them how they liked it make
another one ask them how they liked that
one do it again and again for every
possible temperature and then pick the
one with the lowest suffering the most
enjoyment this is effective very
effective also it can be very time
consuming for a lot of problems and so
we search for a short
now because this is a valley we can use
our physical intuition say hey well what
if we just had a marble and we let it
roll to the bottom of this valley we
wouldn't have to explore every single
piece of it so this is what's behind
gradient descent the way it works is we
start not knowing anything about this
function we make a cup of tea someone
tells us how they like it and then we
change the temperature a little bit we
make another cup of tea just a little
bit cooler we ask someone how they like
that and we find out they actually like
it just a little bit less that tells us
what direction we need to go we need to
make our next cup of tea warmer and the
change the difference between how much
they like those two tells us the slope
tells us the steepness gives us a sense
of how much warmer we can expect to make
that next cup of tea so we make another
one and we repeat the process and then
we again scoot a little ways off to the
side make another cup of tea and figure
out again which direction we need to go
are we do we need to go warmer to make a
better cup or cooler to make a better
cup and we repeat this until we get to
the bottom of the curve you'll know
you're at the bottom when you change the
temperature just a little bit and the
tea drinker says yeah that's exactly the
same I like that just as much as the
last one that means that you're they're
kind of at the flat bottom of the valley
so gradient descent is the first level
trick for brewing fewer cups of tea
there's another thing you can do which
is to use curvature this is kind of an
advanced method is you can make your
original cup of tea and then make one a
little bit warmer and one a little bit
cooler and you can look to see how that
curve of your function goes and if it's
very steep and getting steeper then you
know you can take a giant step because
you're probably not anywhere close to
the bottom and then you can do it again
if that curvature is starting to bottom
out then you can take a smaller step
because you the signal that you're
getting closer to the bottom and it
helps you to do this in fewer steps as
long as your curve is relatively
well-behaved which is not always the
case so ways that this can break imagine
we're doing this a hot day and actually
it turns out that if we were to cool our
tea way down we'd get a really nice iced
tea which turns out to be even more
popular with our tea drinkers but
gradient descent would never find this
gradient descent always rolls down to
the bottom with the nearest valley it
doesn't hop around to see if there are
any valleys hiding anywhere else
another problem is let's say there's a
wiggle on our curve there's something
happening in the environment we have
noisy buses driving by and it affects
how people enjoy their tea we might not
be able to find this very lowest dip
because we might get stuck in a dip
further up the curve similarly if we ask
our tea drinkers to rate their tea
drinking experience on a scale from one
to ten we get these discrete jumps in
our function and if you imagine a marble
rolling downhill it down stairs it
doesn't always work well and it can get
stuck on a step without making it all
the way to the bottom now all of these
things happen in real machine learning
problems another one imagine you have
really picky tea drinkers and if the tea
is anything but perfect they hate it
hate it hate it and so you have these
plateaus on either side and there's no
signal to tell you that if you move in a
little bit you'll find that deep valley
so for cases like this there of course
we can always fall back to exhaustive
exploration it will find the best answer
in every single one of those cases but a
lot of times we just don't have the time
like if
I have to brew and measure the pleasure
drinking pleasure of 10 million cups of
tea to get a good answer to this it's
not going to happen in my lifetime so
luckily there are some things in the
middle that are more sample efficient an
exhaustive exploration but a little bit
more robust than gradient descent things
like genetic algorithms simulated
annealing things that they're defining
characteristic is they have a little bit
of random jumping around there a little
bit of unpredictability and so they make
it harder to slip things by them they
all have their strengths and weaknesses
there tend to be good for different
types of problems or different types of
pathologies in your loss function but
all of them help avoid getting stuck in
the local minima the little small
valleys that gradient descent will get
stuck in they get away with this by
making fewer assumptions and they can
take a little longer to compute the
gradient descent but not nearly so long
as exhaustive exploration you can think
of gradient descent as being like a
Formula One racecar and if you have a
really nice well-behaved track it is
fast but if you put a speed bump in the
truck you're done genetic algorithms
simulated annealing evolutionary
algorithms those are like you know
four-wheel drive pickup truck you can
take a fairly rough road with those and
get where you're going you won't get
there in record time perhaps but you'll
get there and then exhaustive
exploration is like traveling on foot
there is nothing that will stop you from
getting anywhere you can travel little
or literally anywhere but it just might
take you a really really long time so to
illustrate how this works imagine we
have a model that we would like to
optimize we have a research question how
many M&Ms are in a bag of M&Ms so
answering this is easy buy a bag of M&Ms
you eat it 53 you can count those M&Ms
so great we know how many were in
the first bag now when I did this I made
a mistake and I bought another bag and I
tried that one and I got a different
answer so now I can answer 53 or I can
answer 57
either way I'm only right half the time
because I can't capture both bags with
one answer and I could answer somewhere
in the middle but that's never right I
have never opened a bag that had 55 M&Ms
in it so it's unclear that that's the
right answer either and the situation
does not improve with the more bags of
M&Ms that I ate it just gets a little
bit out of control and so I changed my
goal from answering the answer answering
the question right to answering the
question in a way that is less wrong so
in order to do that I have to get really
specific about what I mean by how wrong
I am and to do that
I have this distance function this
deviation which is the difference
between my actual guests and the actual
number of M&Ms in a bag so we call for
for bag number I this deviation is D sub
I it's just the difference between the
guests and the actual number and then I
have to take this deviation and turn it
into a cost so one common way to do this
is to square it it's a nice as the
further away things get kind of the more
costly it is perceived as and it goes up
faster so if there's a bag that's off by
twice as much as another the cost is
four times so I really it penalizes the
things that are way off the things that
are closed it doesn't penalize so much
and if we don't care if we don't want to
overly penalize the things that are way
out there we could use the absolute
value of the deviation so if it's off by
twice as much it'll just be twice the
cost but really we can use anything we
could use the square root of the
absolute value we could use 10 to the
power of the absolute value of this
deviation anything that goes up the
further away you get from zero we'll
stick with squared deviation this is
super common it has some nice properties
and makes for a good example so for the
total cost of any guess that we make if
I guess an estimated bags M&Ms in a bag
then the loss function this fancy curly
QL of that guess is just adding up the
square of the deviation associated with
each bag of M&Ms d1 through DM squared
so each deviation is actually the number
of M&Ms in that bag - the guess so I
square that and we can write down at
fancy summation notation like this so
this is my loss function this is the
total cost this is how wrong I am when I
make a guess and esthe so because we
have computers you can write a little
bit of code and you can do exhaustive
exploration and I can say if I guess
anything between 40 and 70 how wrong
would I be with this data and you can
plot it and visually we can look at this
and we can say hey look there's the
lowest value and we can say what is the
value of the guess they gives me the
lowest loss that's what that argument
that notation means right there and this
best guess is just about fifty five and
a half M&Ms problem solved so this is an
example of numerical optimization where
we calculate this loss function and then
we can do essentially because it
simulated we can do exhaustive
exploration and just pick off the lowest
value now for this particular example
there's a fun other way to find it
we know at the bottom of this curve the
slope is zero it's the only place in the
whole curve where that's true where it's
flat
we can use a little bit of calculus to
find that feel free to tune out if
calculus is not your thing but it's not
too bad so we find the slope of the loss
function with respect to our guesses and
we set it equal to zero and we solve it
to find what for what yes is that true
so we take our loss function this sum of
the square of the differences of the
count and the guess and we take the
derivative of that with respect to our
guests and the derivative of a sum is
the same as the sum of the derivatives
we take the derivative of that just
bring down the exponent so two times
that summed because all that's equal to
zero we can divide it by two and it'll
still be true so now the sum of our
deviations is zero so to further
simplify this it's the sum of all of the
counts of the actual bags times the sum
of our guess once for each bag if we
have M bags then it's M times our guess
and then we can move that to the other
side of the equal sign and divide both
sides by the number of bags M and what
we get is that our best guess is the sum
total of the number of M&Ms we found in
all the bags divided by the number of
bags or the average count per bag so
this is a really slick result and it's
things like this they can make people so
excited about optimization a little bit
of math and calculus you can get this
nice theoretical result now it's worth
noting that this is only true if you use
a deviation squared as your cost
function so that's one reason people
like it so much is because it tends to
give some nice results like this but
there is this analytical shortcut to
find what the best guess is we're going
to come back to this in a few minutes
now how does optimization change
how do we use it in our neural network
to find these weights and these features
so what we want to do we know what our
error function is its how wrong our
guesses are so in this case we have a
labeled data set which means that a
human has already looked at this input
on the left and I said hey that's a
horizontal image the truth values are
what we know should be the right answer
zero votes for everything except
horizontal that should have a vote of
one so let's say initially we've got a
neural network that all the weights are
random and it gives us nonsense results
it says well yeah everything is has some
number associated with it but it's
nothing like the right answer well we
can find the error for each category and
add it up and find a total error and
this is how wrong our neural network
would be for this one example here's our
loss here's our error now the idea with
gradient descent is we're not just
adjusting one thing we're not just
suggesting our guess of the number of
M&Ms we're adjusting many things we want
to go through and adjust every single
weight in every single layer to bring
this error down a little bit now that is
a little bit challenging to do because
in order to do that
one thing you can do is find a
analytical solution like we did before
to go through and move our guess a
little bit up and a little bit down and
find the slope is really expensive when
you consider that this is not a
one-dimensional problem anymore it might
have hundreds or millions of different
weights that we need to adjust so
calculating that gradient that slope
requires hundreds or millions of more
passes through the neural network to
find out which direction is downhill
enter backpropagation so remember we
found the nice analytical solution to
what we had going on in the case of the
mmm estimate so what we would love to be
able to do something like that again if
we had an analytical solution we could
jump right to the right answer so slope
in this case it's change in weight our
sorry it's change in error for a given
change in weight that's the slope here
so there's lots of ways to write that
but Delta error Delta weight DRD weight
will use this partial error partial
weight just cuz it's most correct but
all these things mean the same thing if
I change the weight by one how much will
the error change what is the slope so in
this case it would be minus two and we
would know that we need to increase the
weight in order to get closer to the
bottom this tells us not only the
direction we need to move but gives us a
sense of about how far we should go
doesn't tell us exactly where the bottom
is but it tells us which way it needs to
adjust now if we do know the error
function example we can make a an
analytic solution and we can find that
we can calculate that slope exactly so
in this case the change in error for a
given change in weight is just the
derivative of our error function here
which is in this case is the weight
squared so the derivative is two times
the weight the weight is minus one and
so the answer is a slope of minus two
that tells us what we need to know about
which way to adjust now with neural
networks of course they're a lot more
complex than that but we can actually
analytically compute the slope of the
function where we are we don't know
where the minimum is but we can find the
slope without having to recalculate the
value of everything each time and this
is how it works imagine the world's most
trivial neural network
that has one input one output one hidden
layer with one neuron in it so it's got
an input connected by a weight w1 to an
intermediate value connected by a weight
W to to an output value so the
intermediate value is just x times that
weight so the derivative of Y with
respect to the weight is X what that
means is if I change w1 and I move it by
one then the value of y will change by
the value X whatever X is we have the
slope of this piece of the function
similarly it's straight forward we can
just read off that whatever the value of
y is multiplied by the weight W to we
get e so if we want to find the slope of
the error function for a given change in
Y the answer is w-2 if I changed Y by
one unit then the error changes by the
amount w2 now chaining means that we can
take these two things and just multiply
them together so by inspection we can
see that in this little neural network
if we take X multiply it by w1 multiply
that by w2 we get the error e now what
we'd like to know is if I change that w1
by a certain amount how much does the
error change in this case we just take
that whole expression and take the
derivative with respect to w1 and fairly
trivial bit of calculus it comes out to
be x times w2 and what we can see then
is we can substitute in these steps this
change in Y with respect to w1 is the
same as x w2 is the same as the change
in error with respect to Y
and what this breaks down is if we want
to step down the chain we want to know
how much a change in w1 affects the
error what is de dw1 we can actually
break it down into steps and say okay
well if I change w1 how much does y
change and then if I change Y how much
does the error change this is chaining
and this is what lets us if we know
which way we want to change the error
it lets us calculate how much we can
change this weight to help that happen
and there's nothing to prevent us from
doing this again and again if I have a
weight that's deep into my neural
network and I want to know how much my
error is gonna change if I tweak it up
or down I want to know the slope of my
loss function with respect to that
weight then I can just break it down and
say okay well if I change the weight how
much does a change if I change a how
much does B change I change B how much
does C change and chain it all the way
down now it's called back propagation
because in order to calculate it we
actually need the value at the end we
have to start with the error value in
order to calculate each of these all the
way back down into the depths of the
network but still we can do that now the
way the reason you have to go backwards
is that let's say we want to know what
this should be if I change the error if
I change a how much does the error
change it's like well let's assume that
I already know how much the error is
gonna change if I change B what is this
back propagation step what is the
additional link I need to add to this
chain it's like well it's how much does
B change if I change a if they're
connected by a weight then how do I
incorporate that weight we know that two
neurons connected in this way are
represented by this B is the weight
times the value of a and so we can just
take a little
derivative he ranked at the change in B
with respect to a is w so this step in
the backpropagation change can be
represented by whatever that weight is
cool now we know that we have sums in
our neural network that's another thing
we have to handle if I know how much my
error changes with a change in Z then
how much would it change with a change
in one of the inputs to this to Z where
that input goes into a sum well I have
can write the expression for Z adding up
all the inputs if I want to know how
much Z changes with respect to a change
in a I just take the derivative and it
is turns out to be 1 so this is a
trivial back propagation step now the
most interesting one of all if I know
how much the error changes with respect
to a change in B and then I want to know
how much it changes with the input and
to that sigmoid function then I can just
say ok well a sigmoid function
mathematically looks like this and I can
take the derivative of B with respect to
a and one of the beautiful things about
the sigmoid function is that the
derivative actually looks like this it's
just the value of the function times 1
minus the value of the function which is
one of the reasons that sigmoids perhaps
are so popular and deep neural networks
so this step is also straightforward to
calculate in none of these steps have we
had to recalculate all of the values in
the neural network we've been able to
rely on things that have already been
calculated what the values are at each
of these neurons that's what makes
backpropagation
so mathematically efficient and that's
what allows us to efficiently train
neural networks that is why each element
in a neural network no matter how exotic
it is needs to remain differentiable so
that we can go through this
sighs of finding what the link in the
chain is when we're doing the chain rule
on our derivatives so that we can
compute the back propagation we can back
propagated and again rectified linear
units if we know how much the output
affects a change in error we want to
know how that extends to the input we
can write the function of a rectified
linear unit we can take the derivative
of it and then use that in our chain
rule so imagine now we have this labeled
example we calculate the answer that
this random neural network that's not
special at all it'll give an answer
that's completely wrong and then we back
propagate the error and adjust every one
of those weights a little bit in the
right direction and we do that again and
again after you do that a few thousand
times this stochastic gradient descent
goes from this fully connected totally
random neural network to something that
is a lot more efficient and that is able
to give answers that are much closer to
the right answer so coming back up to
our convolutional neural networks these
are the fully connected layers that's
how they're trained
they can also be stacked this back
propagation up applies not only to these
fully connected layers but also to the
convolutional layers and the pooling
layers we won't go through and calculate
the chain rule for them but you can do
that as well and going through this this
whole stack of different layers gets
trained on a bunch of examples in this
cases of labeled X's and O's give it a
bunch of inputs that we know the right
answer to and we let it adjust all of
those connections not only that it also
adjusts all of the pixels in the
features for each convolutional layer so
it learns not only the weights
but also the features and then over time
those representations become something
that lets it predict very well what is
an X and what is an O on top of that
there are other things that we can use
optimization for so there's a bunch of
decisions here that we haven't addressed
yet how do we know how many features to
put in each convolutional layer how do
we know how big those should be how many
pixels on a side how do we choose the
size and stride of our pooling windows
in our fully connected layers how many
layers do we have and how many hidden
neurons do we put in each each of these
decisions are called hyper parameters
they are also values that we get to
choose but they're the next level up
they kind of control how everything
happens below and in order to see how
well they perform we have to train the
whole thing on all the images start to
finish so but the same principles apply
we can adjust these and choose them to
get the best result possible in a lot of
cases it's worth pointing out that
there's just not enough computation
available in the world to try out all
the possible examples and so what we
have right now are some recipes some
things that researchers have stumbled on
to that seem to work well and they get
reused but there are a lot of places a
lot of combinations of these hyper
parameters that actually haven't been
tried yet and so there is always the
possibility that there are some
combinations that work even much better
than what we've seen so far now we don't
have to use convolutional neural
networks for just images any
two-dimensional or three-dimensional
data works well the thing that matters
is that in this data things that are
closer together are more closely related
than things far away it matters if two
things are in adjacent rows or an
adjacent columns so in images this is
plain
case the location of a pixel in an array
of pixels is part of the information if
you were to randomly jumble the rows and
columns that would lose the information
that's there that's what makes this well
suited to convolutional neural networks
anything you can make look like an image
may also be suited to convolutional
neural networks for instance if you're
working with audio you have a really
nice x-axis your columns can be
subsequent time steps you don't want to
jumble those because the time the order
in which things are current time matters
and you can make your rows the intensity
in different frequency bands going from
low frequency to high frequency again
the order matters there and so being
able to take sound then and make it look
like an image you can apply this
processing to it and find patterns in
the sound that you wouldn't been able to
find conveniently any other way you can
also do this with text with a little bit
of work you can make each of your rows a
different word in the dictionary and
then you can make your columns the
position and sentence or a position
location that it occurs in time now
there are some limitations here
convolutional neural networks only
capture local spatial patterns so if
your data can't be made to look like an
image or if it doesn't make sense to
then they're less useful so for example
imagine you have customer data that has
columns representing things like names
and ages addresses emails purchase
transactions browsing histories and
these customers are listed if you were
to rearrange the rows or rearrange the
columns the information itself wouldn't
really be compromised it would all still
be there it would also be queryable
searchable and interpretable
convolutional neural networks don't help
you here they look for spatial patterns
so if the spatial organization of your
data is not important it will not be
able
find what matters so rule of thumb if
your data is just as useful after
swapping your columns with each other
then you can't use convolutional neural
networks you shouldn't use convolutional
neural networks that's a big takeaway
from this so they're really good at
finding patterns and using them to
classify images that is what is they are
the best at now the takeaway from this
is not that you should go and code up
your own convolutional neural networks
from scratch you can it's a great
exercise there's a lot of fun but when
you go to actually use it there are a
lot of mature tools out there that are
helpful and just waiting to be applied
to this the takeaway from this is that
you will be asked to make a lot of
subtle decisions about how to prepare
your data and feed it in how to
interpret the results and how to choose
these hyper parameters for this it helps
to know what's going to be done with
your data and what it all means so that
you can get the most out of these tools
all right good luck
you